bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce retour critique sur le
documentaire préhistorique planète donc
documentaire pour lequel j'ai déjà fait
une réaction au trailer et qui avait
déjà conquis je pense qu'ils avaient
déjà capté mon attention j'ai envie de
dire par la qualité graphique de ces
dinosaures et sa qualité scientifique
aussi et bien j'ai regardé les cinq
épisodes de la première saison et
j'espère que ce sera pas la dernière
deux préhistorique planète et comme vous
pouvez le voir par mon enthousiasme je
recommande ce documentaire à fond alors
ceux qui me connaissent savent que je
suis très très très sélectif sur la
qualité des documentaires que je regarde
et que je recommande surtout il y en a
pas beaucoup que je recommande en
réalité
notamment les docu fiction c'est à dire
tous ces documentaires ou en fait c'est
juste les dinosaures à l'image des
dinosaures reconstruit en 6 jay et puis
on a juste un léger narratif par dessus
mais où on vous montre jamais de faux
cils typiquement ses documentaires où on
vous montre jamais de faux cils j'y suis
totalement allergique totalement
imperméable d'habitude mais celui là la
qualité graphique l'emportent mais haut
la main je dire là il écrase totalement
j'aime pas les docu fiction d'habitude
parce qu'en fait au moins une fiction on
sait qu'on va te mentir alors que dans
un docu fiction c'est un peu une vérité
enfin c'est un peu un mensonge de
schrödinger c'est à dire qu'on sait pas
si c'est vrai on sait pas si si c'est
faux même ce qui est vrai on ne sait pas
d'où ça sort parce qu'au final est ce
que c'est vrai est-ce que ce qu'on voit
à l'écran c'est vrai parce qu'on a
découvert un fossile ou alors est ce que
c'est vrai parce qu'on a vu d'autres
animaux moderne le faire bas on sait
jamais donc d'habitude j'aime pas les
docu fiction pour ça parce que le peu
qu'on le peu qui est vrai dans un docu
fiction on sait même pas pourquoi c'est
vrai et mail à celui là il emporte take
the cake comme il dit il emporte le
gâteau à l'aise haut la main
la qualité est juste trop énorme trop
trop s'il est juste trop beau ce
documentaire
scientifiquement il et il tient la route
j'ai quelques objections que je
listerait dans le détail dans la
deuxième partie de cette vidéo enfin
dans les cinq autres partis de cette
vidéo six autres partis je sais pas en
combien de parties et sera mais en gros
il va y avoir une petite introduction où
je vais vous donner mon impression
générale ce que je suis déjà en train de
faire
et puis après je veux faire et épisode
par épisode il ya cinq épisodes donc si
vous voulez mon avis général c'est
maintenant et c'est à les y aller le
voir aller voir préhistorique planète
bombardé apple tv plus je suis pas
sponsorisé par apple tv plus mais aller
bombarder apple tv plus il faut les
encourager fauqué une saison 2 faut
qu'il y ait plus de documentaires comme
ça vraiment il faut vraiment qu'ils
aient plus de documentaires de cette
qualité il faut noyer jurassique world
dominion dans sa double
parce que vraiment jurassique world
c'est pas beau à côté de ce documentaire
ce documentaire il est magnifique
regarde hélas ça c'est un arrêt sur
image que je suis en train de vous
montrer là c'est pas un poster
promotionnel
c'est un arrêt sur image que je suis en
train de vous montrer regardez la
finesse des détails regarder la qualité
regardez c'est beau c'est beau ce
documentaire est beau les six gi's sont
magnifiques ils sont tellement beaux 7,6
jihai qu'à un moment du documentaire il
ya un lézard et que je me suis demandé
si le lézard était vrai ou faux c'est à
dire les dinosaures je me pose pas la
question évidemment que les dinosaures
sont faux mais le lézard en le voyant je
me suis dit attends c'est un vrai les
ars house est ainsi jay
ccbbo à ce point là c'est pas le sait
pas parce que le lézard et bien fait je
vais dire mais c'est parce que on est on
a vu tellement de belles choses avant
c'était tellement bien modélisés les
écailles les plumes les poils les
sourcils tout est tellement parfait que
quand tu vois le lézard tu dis mais
attends c'est un vrai ou info c'est un
truc de malade ce documentaire est un
truc de malade j'avais jamais vu une
qualité graphique pareil
donc ouais il faut vraiment voilà si
vous voulez voir un truc à base de
dinosaures cette année c'est
préhistorique planète si vous voulez
retenir quoi que ce soit à propos des
dinosaures sur les dix prochaines années
c'est préhistorique planète c'est
probablement franchement jallet j'allais
l'appeler le documentaire de l'année
mais c'est le documentaire de la
décennie ce documentaire on en reparlera
encore dans 30 ans
en disant [ __ ] ça va pas vieilli
c'est voilà je pense
documentaire c'est le nouveau jurassic
park comme jurassic park premier du nom
à l'époque avait complètement redéfini
ce que le grand public appelé un
dinosaure voilà c'était fini les gros
trucs baveux qui avait la queue qui
traînait par terre jurassic park avait
complètement changé sa préhistorique
planète j'en suis sûr dans trente ans on
en reparle encore comme jurassic park en
disant [ __ ] c'était quand même une
révolution gigantesque on n'avait jamais
vu les dinosaures comme ça avant et ça
ça a défini la mesure étalon de ce à
quoi un dinosaure doit ressembler donc
si vous aimez les dinosaures si vos
enfants aiment les dinosaures si vous
aimez pas les dinosaures si vous aimez
jura c'est quoi si vous aimez pas
jurassique ward aller voir préhistorique
planète voilà regardez préhistorique
planète c'est de la bombe et quand tu
penses qu'il ya des gens de ma
génération qui ont grandi avec des
machins da qui avait enregistré le égale
m6 spécial dinosaures
dangereux égale m6 spécial dinosaures ça
vous repasser en boucle la même chaîne
d' animatronics et il avait genre il
avait genre fait un dessin animé ou un
truc en 3d pas beau de 15 secondes et il
repasse et ça en boucle en boucle en
boucle en boucle où il avait juste filmé
à l'animatronique qui faisait gauche
droite gauche droite
il repasse et ça en boucle pendant le
documentaire parce qu'il n'y avait rien
à montrer et maintenant tu vois ça tu
vois ça 2022 c'est imaginer là comment
imaginer comment notre imagination
aurait se serait enflammé quoi à
l'époque ça aura été donc là je j'envie
les enfants qui vont voir ça vraiment
janvier les enfants qui vont découvrir
les dinosaures avec préhistorique
planète parce que vraiment la bâche
c'est juste voilà c'est juste c'est beau
graphiquement c'est beau
scientifiquement enfin c'est beau
graphiquement c'est juste
scientifiquement en tout cas dans les
grandes lignes on va voir d'après qu'il
ya quand même des gros détails qui sont
qui mérite qu'on s'y arrête
mais en général où il faut bombarder
apple tv faut qu'il fasse une saison 2
c'est pas possible
peuvent pas nous laisser comme ça avec
juste cinq épisodes bon déjà cinq
épisodes de 45 minutes c'est pas mal en
réalité bon évidemment il ya c'est pas
non plus un documentaire qui est
dépourvu de critiques évidemment il ya
quelques défauts le premier défaut est
celui qui m'a le plus choqué parce que
de toute façon c'est la première chose
qu'on voit dans le documentaire c'est la
narration donc je n'ai pas vu la
narration en français il me semble que
c'est doublé par dessus la voix de du
narrateur anglais donc ce qui est pas
spécialement beau mais en anglais c'est
david attenborough qui fait la narration
alors david attenborough ça a beau être
une figure légendaire du documentaire
animalier du documentaire en général
en angleterre bon chez nous il n'est pas
si connu que ça mais c'est surtout le
côté où david attenborough il a plus de
80 ans je crois même qu'il ya plus de
quatre-vingt dix ans maintenant je
connais pas son âge exact mais il est
fatigué david attenborough il est
vraiment très fatigué il a du mal à
reprendre son souffle entre entre les
phrases je veux dire jeu il y là il a le
droit à une retraite je pense il a droit
à une retraite plus que méritée david
attenborough il a beaucoup donné pour
les documentaires il a beaucoup donné
même pour la vulgarisation scientifique
la science et tout mais là il a vraiment
du bon sens qu'il a du mal à faire la
narration et on sent qu'il a du mal à
respirer entre les phrases alors tant
qu'il est en voix off ça va m'aider
qu'il est à l'écran ça se sent ça se
voit et puis après dans mes autres
craintes confirmées donc je vous invite
à revoir le trailer pouvoir les endroits
où j'avais déjà mis des bémols rien
qu'en regardant le trailer mais bon ben
il ya la modélisation de l'eau ça y'a
pas à dire la modélisation de l'eau
c'est toujours un énorme problème et ça
n'a pas manqué le premier épisode on
voit les plésiosaures comme des gens les
voiliers dans le trailer aller en dehors
et est sous l'eau en série et
c'est pas très bon c'est pas très beau
donc la modélisation de l'eau ils l'ont
un peu ils l'ont un peu galles et ils
ont un peu galéré ça se voit et ça se
voit aussi quand il ya le dénommé russe
quand il ya le dénommé russe qui se
relève de l'eau en fait il ya donc il
est plein de il est plein de pas de
poils mais de plumes du coup mais ça
ressemble à des poils il ya une fourrure
une genre de fourrure de plumes et donc
quand ils se soulèvent de l'eau là on
voit qu'ils ont utilisé une marionnette
typiquement c'est là qu'on voit que vu
la qualité de la modélisation de l'eau
dans le premier épisode
arrivé je crois c'est l'épisode 3d noke
russe on voit quand ils se soulèvent de
l'eau c'est une marionnette je dis donc
c'est ce qu'il ya de bien c'est bien du
coup ils ont utilisé un mélange de
marionnettes et 2 et 2 et d'effets
spéciaux comme pour le petit lézard le
petit lézard je pense ils ont utilisé un
mélange d'effets spéciaux quand ils se
déplacent et d'image réel quand il bouge
pas donc comme ça le détail des écailles
et tout ça est vraiment impeccable vu
que c'est un vrai mais du coup quand il
se déplace bien il faut le faire aller
là où on veut que le scénario l'amène
parce que c'est quand même scénarisé
c'est un docu fiction donc on la mène là
où le scénario veulent l'emmener et puis
après quand ils s'arrêtent pouf on fait
un plan serré sur son sur sa tête et
c'est donc le lézard c'était je pense un
mix entre des images réelles et de
prises de vues réelles et décide j'y
aille donc des effets spéciaux
numériques
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas le psy
gi's le terme sidiailles dans mes autres
crac qui se sont confirmées les autres
craintes que j'avais formulée dans le
trailer en regardant le trailer et qui
se sont confirmées c'est tout sur le
crétacé donc n'espérez pas voir des
dinosaures du trias du jurassique même
du début du crétacé c'est tout tout le
prémice en fait du documentaire c'est de
vous montrer ce qui se passait à
l'époque de tyrannosaure de
tyrannosaurus rex en l'occurrence donc
tout et du crétacé terminal terminal
coincé fin fin du crétacé tout donc
c'est justifié on va dire dans un
certain sens parce que bah c'est plus
facile on va dire de documenter le les
dinosaures de cette époque puisque c'est
les plus récents il faut voir que tyreke
sylla que ce 66 millions d'années enfin
66 à 70 millions d'années par rapport à
nous c'est moins de distance que ce qui
le sépare luis da dinosaures du trias
donc on connaît vachement mieux du coup
les dinosaures du de la fin du crétacé
de l'époque de t-rex tout simplement
parce qu'ils sont vachement moins vieux
voilà et d'ailleurs même même pour t-rex
les dinosaures du trias s'était déjà des
vieux fossile c'est c'est con à dire
mais enfin ça paraît évident mais mais
quand on y pense les premiers dinosaures
du trias était déjà des vieux fossile à
l'époque du t-rex
donc et donc ça ça rend du coup l'époque
de trier rex balle à ça la rend la plus
facile à documenter c'est la con plus de
fossiles ils sont très bien préservés
ils n'ont pas trop morflé dans leurs
tronches niveau niveau géologique donc
et on en a beaucoup donc c'est l'époque
la plus facile à documenter j'ai envie
de dire la fin du crétacé puisque c'est
la plus proche de nous c'est aussi une
époque où les angiospermes était déjà
bien répandu à la fin du crétacé il y
avait déjà pas mal d'envieux sperme et
du coup ça rend les prises de vues
réelles plus simple parce qu'évidemment
les décors la plupart des décors sont
des prises de vues réelles je crois qu'à
un moment on reconnaît même très très
bien monument de vallée puis à plein de
décors qu'on reconnaît très bien qu'ils
sont des prises de vues réelles qui
n'ont pas été modélisé et ça le fait de
faire se dérouler l'action à la fin du
crétacé ça permet que dans le décor se
promènent quelques enjeux sperme voilà
quelques plantes à fleurs les
angiospermes c'est des plantes à fleurs
qui n'étaient pas là pendant la plupart
du règne des dinosaures mais qui à la
fin du crétacé était déjà là et bien
implantés elle était cool quoi elle
était au frais et avec les plantes à
fruits je crois y avait pas encore de
plantes à fruits à l'époque il ya
évidemment il en manquait pas mal des
plantes à fleurs mais si vous voulez ça
devient tolérable de filmer des plantes
à fleurs au crétacé alors que ça allait
complètement pas au jurassique et au
trias si vous filmez des plantes à
fleurs au jurassique et au trias et au
jurassique notamment le début du
jurassique c'est chaud c'est siobhan
anneaux donc il faut bien faire gaffe
enfin du couffo c'est un truc est
marrant d'ailleurs c'est quand on
regarde les autres documentaires si vous
regardez sur la terre des dinosaures
vous vous êtes probablement posé la
question mais pourquoi ils vivent
toujours dans le désert ces [ __ ] de
dinosaures bas la raison pour laquelle
ils vivent toujours toujours dans le
désert c'est que c'est à peu près le
seul endroit où on rencontre ni plantes
à fleurs ni graminées parce que les
graminées à l'époque des dinosaures
alors il y en avait peut-être mais elle
formait pas des grandes plaines
herbeuses elle était très très très très
bien caché les graminées donc
dire qu'à dinosaure herbivore c'est un
léger abus de langage puisque bon
herbivore on nous on comprend qu'ils
mangent des végétaux mais c'est vrai
qu'on doit dire végétative or en réalité
parce qu'il n'y avait pas d'herbe c'est
en tout cas il n'y avait pas de grandes
étendues herbeuses au temps des
dinosaures même à la fin du crétacé
donc là où je veux en venir c'est que si
vous vous êtes jamais posé la question
du pourquoi au trias et au jurassique on
vous montre toujours des dinosaures qui
vivent dans des déserts c'est parce
qu'on n'a pas de décors réels ou se
faire dérouler l'action on a très très
peu de patch de forêt
bas des forêts qui sont fait 100% de
gymnospermes le problème c'est qu'on les
retrouve que dans les hautes latitudes
donc ces grandes forêts de conifères on
les retrouve que dans les hautes
latitudes ce qui veut dire qu'il fait
froid hors l'époque des dinosaures il
faisait chaud essentiellement on va voir
dans le documentaire que ce n'est pas le
cas tous les partout mais je veux dire
il faisait essentiellement chaud à
l'époque des dinosaures si on veut
montrer une jungle luxuriante sans aucun
sens aucune plante à fleurs sans aucun
feu lui ça va être compliqué c'est très
compliqué c'est même limite impossible
en fait il ne reste que quelques forêts
par ci par là qui sont encore fait
essentiellement d'acacia ou bien de de
fougères arborescentes il en existe
quelques patchs dans le monde mais il en
existe pas suffisamment pour faire des
grandes séries documentaires quoi donc
faire se dérouler sa au crétacé c'est
explicable mais du coup on sacrifie
quelque chose d'important c'est la
diversité vous qui n'avez peut-être pas
l'habitude des dinosaures vous avez
peut-être vu plein de nouveaux
dinosaures dans ce documentaire mais en
réalité tous ces dinosaures ils
appartiennent essentiellement à la
famille des tyrannosauridés à la famille
des hadrons au rider [ __ ] qu'est ce
qu'on en bouffe des autres autorités
dans ce documentaire le lire des bec de
canard voilà partout tout le temps
qu'ils sont bien fait encore une fois
ils sont bien fait d'ailleurs on notera
le bec et effectivement le becks va vers
le bas c'est pas juste un bec de canard
comme un canard c'est à la fin il va
vers le bas exactement comme les momies
dan rose or qu'on a retrouvés l'ont
démontré
donc ça ils ont été très soigneux de ce
point de vue là mais c'est surtout elle
vous voyez essentiellement des cadres
aux orres essentiellement des
tyrannosauridés donc vous remarquerez
que tous les grands carnivores ils ont
deux doigts c'est des tyrannosauridés
même s'ils ont l'air d'avoir des formes
très différentes et qu'il les appels
avec des noms différents les ptérosaures
c'est tous des as d'arc idée quasiment
et puis il ya quelques drôme et aux
orres par ci par là quelques
troodontidés enfin le reste c'est 10% de
ce qu'ils voient là il reste après ça il
reste 10 % du temps d'écran une fois que
vous retirez les à drouot rider les
tyrannosauridés les les as d'arc idée il
reste 10 % du temps d'écran et ce dix
pour cent du temps d'écran est partagé
entre drôme et aux orres terry
dinosaures enfin plein de familles le
point enfin là où je veux en venir c'est
que il ya quand même pas beaucoup de
diversité du coup ils se sont vraiment
limités à cause de ce cahier des charges
de faire se peut faire se dérouler le
truc à la fin du crétacé il se sont
limitées au niveau du cou de la
diversité qui pouvait montrer vous
verrez aucun ichthyosaures par exemple y
en avait pu à la fin du crétacé vous
verrez vous verrez les seuls grand
sauropode que vous verrez sont tous des
titanosaures ya pas de diplodocus ou de
bon là il ya que des titanosaures les et
vous verrez aucun stégosaure typiquement
puisqu'ils sont déjà éteindre les aloses
or là si vous aimez bien les aloses or
vous n'en verrez pas enfin bref voilà si
vous aimez bien brachiosaures vous en
verrez pas non plus donc il ya pas
beaucoup de diversité du coup du fait
qu'ils se sont limités à ça une autre de
mes craintes qui s'étaient confirmées
alors c'était plus un truc où je les
attendais en fait plutôt que plus qu'une
crainte j'avais dit je les attends sur
les sauropodes elle était rose or parce
que c'est généralement le truc où on
sait pas trop on sait pas trop si vous
voulez le problème c'est comme j'ai dit
il on que des as d'arc idée sauf que les
as d'art qu'il est de la fin du crétacé
ils sont tous gigantesque donc du coup
on va on vous attend pour voir comment
vous allez les faire décoller c'est seas
d'art qu'il y ait enfin c'est cette
terre aux hordes gigantesques et pareil
pour les sauropodes c'est tous des
titanosaures donc quasiment tous des
machins gigantesque donc c'est pareil
j'attends de voir comment vous allez
faire déplacer ces sauropodes [ __ ]
j'ai pas été déçu as et el atteuf alors
par exemple dans ce documentaire ils ont
introduit quid zalko atlus et à
trekkopje rixe donc les deux plus
grandes des roseaux reconnu basiquement
et alors tous les 200 vols du sol comme
des fleurs sans aucun effort il faut
quand même prendre en question le fait
que d'une il ya le poids il faut quand
même qu'ils arrivent à développer une
portance suffisamment forte pour
décoller leur poids même s'il était
relativement léger par rapport à leur
taille le fait qu'ils aient des ailes
gigantesque ça les rend plus fragile je
veux dire une baguette plus elle est
longue plus elle risque de péter et puis
et donc leur dois ce sont des
basiquement leur zèle elles sont
soutenues par leurs longs doigts qui
sont des très longue baguette donc très
fragile a priori surtout qu'ils étaient
creux c'est oh et puis vous avez
l'histoire de la membrane dont on n'est
pas complètement sûr de la solidité non
plus alors on suppose que cette membrane
était très épaisse mais bon de toute
façon à mon avis l'est les doigts au
répété avant la membrane quoi donc le
truc c c'est vraiment ça et on voit
cette terre aux orres donc prendre appui
sur leurs bras avant et s'élançait donc
ça c'est quelque chose qui a été
développé dans les années 2010 cette
théorie du lancement avec les bras avant
c'est un truc qu'on voit aussi chez
certaines chauve-souris apparemment et
donc ça j'ai pas de problème avec ça le
truc c'est que vraiment une fois qu'ils
ont pris leurs leur lancent leur appui
sur leurs bras avant ils déploient leurs
ailes et ils s'envolent c'est la magie
c'est ta gueule c'est magique il est en
l'air il n'y a pas de galère il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a même pas une course
pour prendre de l'élan où il n'y a même
pas le jeter de la falaise ou quoi que
ce soit ou essayer de prendre de la
hauteur d'une façon ou d'une autre ou de
prendre un thermique ou non non juste où
ces deux juste de se mettre notamment la
digue opté rixe on le voit se mettre sur
une plage pour s'envoler on aurait pu au
moins nous dire qu'il y avait du vent tu
vois sur cette plage un tuyau l histoire
de dire voilà là il attrape le vent et
hop tu vois il s'est lancé il arrive à
attraper le vent et ça lui permet de
s'envoler non non non ils s'envolent par
magie vraiment ils prennent appui pour
et ils sont en l'air
donc ça je les attendais sur les
ptérosaures et j'ai vraiment puisé des
jupes
c'est dommage bon c'est un peu dommage
vu la qualité par ailleurs du
documentaire c'est un peu dommage de de
merde et là dessus mais bon comme je les
dis comme je le dis en faisant de
trailer en faisant la critique du
trailer toute façon les ptérosaures
comme quiz alcoa est lui c'est et a été
coopté ax ils emmerdent la physique quoi
je veux dire il emmerde les règles de
base qu'on connaît de la physique donc
toute façon je peux pas leur les blâmer
au niveau des sauropodes c'est pareil
j'aurais j'aurais bien aimé voir des
sauropodes lourd lent
mais efficace voilà mais non il faut
qu'on nous montre des sauropodes en
train de se dresser sur la patte de
derrière de se coller des droites
de faire des trucs de malade y en a un
moment il ya un sauropode qui tombe à
terre et jean à sauropodes qui tombe à
terre enfin faut
surtout un titanosaures là on peut
cédric lotus donc l'un des plus gros
titanosaures qui ait jamais existé mais
enfin un truc pareil là qui tombe au sol
c'est tellement lourd que normalement tu
vois la cage thoracique fier
puisque je le rappelle plus on est gros
plus on est fragile par rapport à sa
taille donc un gros animal est loin
d'être solide au contraire un gros
animal est très fragile et donc
basiquement s'il s'effondre
vous le verrez pas vous le verrez pas se
relever quoi et encore moins enfin là en
l'occurrence on voit pas se relever on
le voit juste faire
mais bon déjà rien qui arrivait ce
serait impossible quoi il y en a un
autre se reportent convoi dormir
allongée
enfin je veux dire il suffit de regarder
les éléphants même les chevaux je veux
dire il essaye le plus possible de ne
pas dormir allongé alors je ne dis pas
qu'ils ne font pas du tout les éléphants
et les chevaux dorment aussi allongé
c'est pas un problème mais en face ça
aurait été bien justement de nous
montrer un petit peu de variété de
comportements est justement de les faire
dormir debout sachant qu'ils ont des
membres qui sont très proches de ceux
des éléphants des jambes et des bras et
des jambes très proches de ceux des
éléphants ça a été très très intéressant
de les voir dormir debout et nous
expliquait il dort debout parce que si
s'allonge c'est quand même une dépense
d'énergie considérable pour se relever
est ce que c'est ça c'est pas qu'ils
risquent de se péter rende en se
relevant ce n'est pas le problème
peuvent très bien se coucher et se
relever ça c'est pas un problème c'est
une dépense d'énergie par contre
considérable énergie qui est difficile à
rapporter
quand on est déjà gigantesque par
ailleurs c'est à dire que imaginer règne
pour faire fonctionner la turbine il
faut un max d'énergie rend plus pour
faire des efforts non nécessaires comme
ceux relevés alors qu'on aurait pu
dormir debout typiquement c'est c'est
non négligeable c'est non négligeable
donc s'arrêter ça aurait été le genre de
choses que j'aurais bien aimé voir banon
la place on nous montre des sauropodes
qui font des saltos arrière qui font
qu'ils font qui jongle qui se tiennent
sur une boule et qui jongle comme ça
vous savez comme des lésés mais machin
dans les cirques
donc ouais voir des dinosaures actifs ok
mais pas au prix de la logique quoi je
veux dire le voir des dinosaures actifs
ok c'est cool mais les sauropodes ce que
je dis les sauropodes ils n'ont pas une
liberté d'action infinie quoi bon bref
et il y avait aussi le dernier bémol le
dernier gros bémol qui s'est confirmée
c'est lé comportement genre il n'existe
aucun enfin je veux dire dans tout le
temps tout le documentaire quasiment
tous les dinosaures convoi se déplace en
troupeau ou chasse en meute ou ont des
soins parentaux que même même les
mammifères modernes non non pas des
comme ça où pratiquer des parades
nuptiales
complètement complètement fille folle il
s'est complètement fou voilà c'est ils
ont vraiment ouvert les vannes en fait
complètement sur les comportements et
juste bah oui et non en fait c'est
encore une fois c'est bien de nous
montrer les dinosaures comme étant des
animaux actifs avec des comportements
proches de ceux des oiseaux modernes
mais tous les oiseaux modernes n'ont pas
des comportements complexes tous les
oiseaux modernes ont pas des parades
nuptiales de dengue et
surtout quand on voit que beaucoup des
comportements qu'ils ont copié viennent
en réalité des mammifères est pas tant
que ça des oiseaux parce que chasser en
meute ils ont beau dire parce qu'il ya
toute la petite série qui explique qu'il
ya une une série par dessus la série qui
explique un peu les making of et
pourquoi ils ont pris telle décision etc
ils ont beau nous dire qu'il ya plein
d'oiseaux qui pratiquent la chasse en
groupe
bah non en réalité un a pas tant que ça
et c'est surtout les buses de harris en
réalité alors les corbeaux peuvent
chasser en groupe éventuellement enfin
les corbeaux c'est surtout des
charognards mais
ok les corbeaux peuvent chasser en
groupe ça fait deux sur dix mille c'est
pas des masses il n'ya pas plaint
d'espèces d'oiseaux qui chassent en
groupe donc la chasse en meute c'est un
truc de loups chez les mammifères voilà
c'est un truc de lyon chez les
mammifères une fois de plus mais bon
bref donc ça aurait été bien de nous
montrer une diversion un peu plus de
diversité de comportements
notamment parce qu'il ya quasiment pas
de dinosaures solitaire en fait dans
leur histoire on a très très peu il y en
a je dis pas qu'il y en a pas parce
qu'évidemment quand il suffit que je
dise ça pour qu'il y en ait un qui me
fasse la liste tu sais en commentaire
mais mais il y en a des dinosaures
solitaire dans ce dans ce docu en terme
et je veux dire on assiste quasiment pas
dessus on ne pointe pas du doigt le fait
qu'ils chassent en solo par exemple
par contre on insiste beaucoup sur ceux
qui chassent en meute à ceux qui
chassent en meute eux ils chassent en
meute un ceux qui se déplacent en
troupeau faut bien montrer ils se
déplacent entreposés vous dire ça
s'arrête à un point en fait où tout a
tellement des comportements complexes qu
on a même des donc les plésiosaures qui
ont des soins parentaux
alors que bon les plésiosaures
normalement ils sont quand même plus
proche pour autant qu'on sache s'ils
sont ils sont quand même plus proche des
lézards que des oiseaux donc je veux
dire il n'y avait pas ce n'était pas
obligé de leur donner des soins
parentaux le dire donc les plésiosaures
ils ont des soins parentaux les
ammonites se déplace en troupeau je veux
dire y'a rien qui a un comportement
simple de base dans cette histoire
voilà et c'est pas que j'ai envie de
voir des dinosaures à comportements
simples de base de lézard c'est pas ça
le problème le problème c'est que encore
une fois on tire un trait sur la
diversité c'est le même problème qu'avec
le fait de faire se passer ça au crétacé
c'est qu'on tire un trait sur une
diversité comportementale on pourrait
nous montrer des comportements solitaire
intéressant on pourrait nous montrer des
des comportements d'abandon par les
parents le dire ça se montre salle et
les parents ils pondent leurs oeufs et
il se casse bon alors on pourrait nous
montrer ça à nos montres pas ça c'est
des soins parentaux en veux tu en voilà
quoi donc là pour le coup sur la terre
des dinosaures étaient un peu plus
fidèle de ce point de vue là on n'avait
plus de diversité de comportements bas
en même temps on avait aussi beaucoup
plus de diversité de dinosaure dans sur
la terre des dinosaures bon bref pour
conclure donc sur cette première partie
je dirais que est-ce que ce documentaire
est le nouveau sur la terre des
dinosaures non ce documentaire est le
nouveau jurassic park au sens où
jurassic park premier du nom et aucun
autre jurassic park premier du nom il
est sorti en 1993 donc il y a
trente ans maintenant
quasiment 30 ans maintenant il redéfinit
ce que les gens pensaient être les
dinosaures il a redéfini l'image que le
grand public se faisaient des dinosaures
et aujourd'hui encore les gens le
regardent en se disant [ __ ] ça a
quasiment pas vieilli je pense que dans
trente ans les gens regarderont
préhistorique planète en se disant vache
ça a pas vieilli d'une ride et wau
comment les dinosaures il était
avant-gardiste
voilà donc donc oui je le recommande oui
allez le voir et oui il a des défauts
mais honnêtement il n'y a aucun de ces
défauts là qu'ils étaient suffisamment
grand pour que je bous de montplaisir et
pourtant ils partaient perdre en sachant
que c'est un docu fiction il partait
perdons donc voilà je le recommande sans
modération et je ne suis pas sponsorisé
par apple tv + n'ont donc allé le voir
sur apple tv plus vous êtes même pas
obligé je croyais à je sais même plus
qui avait expliqué que si vous prenez si
vous prenez le test sur 30 jours je
crois vous pouvez le regarder gratos et
puis
puis vous désabonner dans la foulée
[Rires]
je vous encourage pas à le faire hein je
dis juste que c'est une possibilité
mais voilà allez le voir aller le voir
il faut qu'il fasse une saison 2 donc
allez le voir bon maintenant on commence
les détails les détails avec en premier
donc l'épisode sur la côte la côte donc
les et puis l'épisode sur la mer en
général donc commençons déjà par
enfoncer des portes ouvertes ce mot
açores est parfait j'ai jamais vu un
mozart de cette qualité il est
impeccable donc ils l'ont fait ils l'ont
fait avec la queue qui part vers le bas
donc la colonne vertébrale qui part vers
le bas avec un petit lob vers le haut
exactement comme ce qu'on peut voir sur
les fossiles ils l'ont fait avec des
grosses lèvres et des grosses gencives
comme les warrants moderne donc
contrairement à ce qu'on voit dans
jurassic world ou là ils prennent le
parti de le faire ressembler plus à un
crocodile puisque les crocodiles sont
aquatique et qu'ils ont pas de lèvres
mais là ils ont pris le pari le parti de
le faire ressembler plus avare en cas un
animal aquatique
c'est tout à fait louable mais du coup
ça marche très bien il le montre en
train de muer c'est plutôt intéressant
et puis montre comment les petits y
montre c'est ça que j'aime bien aussi
c'est qu'ils montrent comment des
animaux gigantesques deviennent eux
mêmes des écosystèmes ça c'est ça c'est
un truc qu'on voit pas assez souvent
dans les documentaires c'est surtout
avec les sauropodes et même dans le même
temps préhistoriques planète je trouve
qu'ils n'ont pas assez montré c'est
comment un sauropode ou un mozart par
exemple des trucs qui sont absolument
gigantesque de ville la surface de leur
peau devient elle-même amini écosystèmes
pour tout un tas de petits parasites et
tout un tas de petits machins commensaux
qui vont se nourrir de leurs peaux
mortes qui vont ou qui vont se nourrir
du lichen qui pousse sur le dos des
sauropodes
parce qu'évidemment les machins ils sont
gigantesques et il bouge à deux à
l'heure enfin en tout cas normalement il
aurait dû bouger à deux à l'heure pas
dans ce documentaire la voilà des
machins il bouge à deux à l'heure bon
bah c'est comme les c'est comme des des
énarques relais comment s'appelle c'est
comme les paresseux les paresseux ils
ont deux là ils ont des algues qui le
repousse dessus parce qu'ils sont lents
et qui bouge pas avec voilà est donc là
je j'aimerais bien voir mois des
sauropodes sur le dos desquels pouce du
lichen et le lichen se fait manger par
des petits herbivores et ses petits
vases herbivores se font eux mêmes
mangés par des carnivores carnivore qui
se nourrissent aussi d autres petits
animaux qui vivent là et qui sont et qui
se nourrissent des peaux mortes du
dinosaure etc j'aimerais bien voir ça
bon là il nous montre sa avec le mozart
donc les petits animaux les petits
crustacés là qui viennent se nourrir des
peaux mortes de la mue du mozart je
trouve ça super intéressant c'est voilà
ça c'est une proposition cool c'est une
proposition qui est canon quoi ça envoie
du boudin quoi donc il ya ça il ya le
combat le combat entre les mots à tort
c'est quelque chose qu'on avait déjà vu
dans le trailer dont je vais pas revenir
dessus mais on a des fossiles et
d'ailleurs ils le disent dans la
narration on a les fossiles qui montre
qu'il se battait et ça c'est bien ça
c'est bien quand ça c'est quand ça
arrive il faut le dire ça arrive pas
souvent dans ce documentaire hélas mais
quand ça arrive il faut le dire donc ça
c'est super cool
bon là où ça marche moins bien par
contre c'est les ptérosaures comme j'ai
dit les ptérosaures il était enfin déjà
sur le côté décollage du ptérosaures il
était un peu en roue libre il savait pas
trop quoi en faire donc c'est un peu
l'envol magique
et mais il ya en plus ce côté où ils ont
décidé de montrer les ptérosaures
d'afrique du nord et j'ai rien contre ça
j'ai rien contre le fait de montrer des
dinosaures dafri enfin des dinosaures
des ptérosaures enfin de la biodiversité
mésozoïque africaine ce genre je suis
pour un jeu le dire en tant que
paléontologues en afrique je plusse plus
je pousse vers le haut par contre
choisir les ptérosaures ce n'est
peut-être pas l'idée du siècle parce que
en afrique en réalité enfin en afrique
du nord l'année je visualise exactement
quel article ils ont utilisé pour faire
ça il n'y a pas un seul crâne il ya
enfin ces c'est juste des petits
morceaux c'est la plupart des trucs sont
à peine identifiables ceux qui sont
identifiables c'est juste des humérus ou
d
c'est juste des eaux des membres ou des
choses comme ça il n'y a pas de crâne
n'y a pas de matériel hyper diagnostic
ya pas de beau matériel c'est du
matériel important scientifiquement mais
il n'y a pas de jolies choses qui ont
été sortis du
du crétacé supérieur d'afrique du nord
il n'y a pas de jolies fossiles et là on
nous montre genre un ptérosaure alors
c'est une espèce ou iliad et donc des
représentants géant là comme celui qui
est à l'écran des grands mâles qui ont
ces espèces des normes crête sur la tête
alors ça je peux vous assurer on en a
jamais retrouvé en afrique ça scénique
tozeur mais qui n'a pas été retrouvée du
tout en afrique du nord scénique toso
requis à cette crête là
et donc qui vient pas de là alors
peut-être qu'il a des proches parents en
afrique du nord mais enfin de la faire
l'hypothèse qu'il avait une crête ce non
pas forcément donc il ya ces grands
mâles qui ont ces grandes crète alors
dire en plus que c'est que les mâles qui
avait la crête c'est pareil c'est
spéculatifs et puis vous avez des
femelles qui n'ont pas la crète et vous
avez des mâles qui sont petit et qui
imitent les femelles pour pouvoir mieux
les [ __ ]
alors et ça c'est pareil c'est un
comportement qu'on retrouve chez les
mammifères hacker petit peu chez les
oiseaux je suis même pas sûr sophie ak
miss plume ne m'a pas n'était pas très
affirmative sur le côté est ce que les
oiseaux font ça aussi
c'est surtout un truc de mammifères
apparemment de ces les serres qui sont
connus pour faire ça les cervidés sont
connus pour finale aller les petits
mâles hop ils s'introduisent en douce au
sens propre et au sens figuré
voilà donc on voit les ptérosaures faire
ça et bon ça c'est sorti de nulle part
quoi ça va vraiment les ptérosaures à
chaque fois parce qu'il ya deux épisodes
au moins où ils vous montrent des
ptérosaures d'afrique du nord est
vraiment tu vois des trucs
ils ont ouvert les vannes quoi ils ont
complètement ouvert les vannes c'est de
la folie c'est la grande folie voilà
il ya eu les ammonites les ammonites ça
pas mal fait râler les ammonites ça pas
mal fait râler parce qu'elles sont
bioluminescente on les voit voilà leur
petit tentacules qui brille dans le noir
alors moi personnellement bon ça m'a pas
choqué sur le coup ça faisait vraiment
des belles images là pour le coup c'est
totalement justifié par un intérêt
purement artistique il n'y a pas de
science derrière ça je n'y a pas eu de
science derrière la décision si vous
voulez de mettre des ammonites
bioluminescente vu que du il ya eu que
le mec qui s'est dit moi je veux des
ammonites bioluminescente et j'en veux
un million pour que ça fasse un grand
nuage de lumière comme ça et tout ça les
scientifiques vous avez quelque chose à
dire en fait tu vois ta gueule cheveux
voilà
à peu près sûr que ça s'est passé
quelque chose comme ça
non en réalité il ya des ya des
céphalopodes bioluminescente notamment
les sèche donc ça aurait peut-être été
plus judicieux de faire des belles emnid
bioluminescente plutôt que des ammonites
donc il y a des céphalopodes
bioluminescence mais bon la
bioluminescence au final c'est pas
choquant parce qu'ils disent les
ammonites viennent des abysses pour
venir se reproduire à la surface ah bon
bah voilà les abysses il ya une
justification biologique expliqué dans
la narration qui nous dit pourquoi elles
sont bioluminescente elles viennent des
abysses voilà donc ça au moins c'était
justifié aussi légèrement
scientifiquement voilà il ya des
céphalopodes bioluminescence et les
ammonites en question viennent des
abysses qui explique qu'elles sont
bioluminescente donc admettons moi ce
qui m'a emmerdé plus c'est le côté wayne
le côté encore des trucs qui se baladent
en troupeau et encore des trucs avec une
parade nuptiale pas possible ouais c'est
à dire tu es déjà là arriver là tu es
déjà au premier épisode était en train
de te dire alors j'ai vu une parade
nuptiale de plésiosaure j'ai vu une
parade nuptiale de macha je crois qu'on
a ce moment la on a déjà vu le t-rex
avoir une parade nuptiale enfin je sais
plus mais j'ai déjà vu j'ai déjà vu
trois parades nuptiales quoi
vous avez l'intention d'en montrer
encore beaucoup donc je veux dire les
plésiosaures ils ont d une parade
nuptiale sorti de nulle part tu les vois
pendant deux secondes faire bloup bloup
bloup faire le bouchon comme ça
pourquoi vous pourquoi vous avez fait à
faire ça vaut plésiosaures alors que ça
sert à rien dans le scénario c'était
juste c'est vraiment le côté dire on va
on va rendre les reptiles mais
mésozoïque
super actif et super comme des oiseaux
bah oui mais enfin ça c'est des
plésiosaures quoi il n'y a pas besoin y
a pas besoin vous auriez pu les faire se
comporter comme des iguanes aquatique
par exemple sera était peut-être plus
marrant plus différent du moins je sais
pas enfin c'est des propositions c'est
juste le côté ou encore une fois ça
manque de diversité dans les
comportements là c'est à chaque fois
c'est il se déplace en troupeau pour
aller à un endroit et cet endroit c'est
là qu'ils font leurs parades nuptiales
et c'est toujours toujours ça c'est un
peu répétitif du coup et déjà dès le
premier épisode en fait c'est wow c'est
déjà la troisième parade nuptiale que je
vois on va nous montrer que ça vraiment
donc les ammonites ça aurait peut-être
était bien justement pour une fois de
nous montrer de nous les montrer je sais
pas bon en train de faire des deux je
sais pas de se nourrir de se déplacer
les ammonites c'est vachement gracieux
cc des céphalopodes quoi nous les
montrer en train de faire autre chose je
sais pas nous montrer une ammonite
géante pourquoi pas ça aurait pu être
intéressant ou au contraire des
ammonites tout petit bon bref j'en sais
rien j'en sais rien évidemment je ne
vais pas c'est facile de dire il y
aurait fallu un il ya qu'à faut qu'on
monsieur et madame il ya qu'à faut qu'on
c'est facile à dire à faire mais moi en
tout cas au bout d'un moment je me suis
j'ai déjà au dès le premier épisode
j'étais en train de me dire ouais ça
fait beaucoup de parade nuptiale
et donc c'est ammonites se sont se sont
à peu près les seuls l'invertébré sur
lesquelles on va vraiment passé du temps
aussi dans ce documentaire ya pas
beaucoup de encore une fois il n'y a pas
beaucoup de diversité en termes de
dinosaures mais il ya aussi pas beaucoup
de diversité à l'extérieur des
dinosaures à l'extérieur des dinosaures
on va à peine s'arrêter sur les oiseaux
il ya trois frame avec un mammifère qui
se fait capturer par un trou dont il est
et il ya des ammonites il ya il ya
quelques il ya quelques passages avec
des moustiques des mouches et des
scarabées voilà
mais c'est pareil c'est vraiment ces
focus sur les dinosaures quoi c'est
ultra focus sur les dinosaures et sur
les reptiles marins dans cet épisode sur
les côtes évidemment après c'est
ammonites à sont pas mal alors elles ont
dit bras donc ce qui est le nombre de
bras primitif pour des céphalopodes
elle ressemble aux vampires aux de ty et
c'est à dire que les c'est à dire que
les tentacules sont reliés par une
membrane de peau donc c'est un choix en
fait de les avoir fait ressembler aux
vampires haute idée comme on n'a pas de
tissus mous d'ammonites ils font ce
qu'ils veulent j'ai envie de dire mais
en tout cas ils ont fait ce choix
intéressant avec les ammonites de
représenter le mal plus petit que la
femelle ce qui a été démontré chez
certaines ammonites effectivement le mal
enfin du moins c'est pas que ça a été
démontrée évidemment ça a été suggérée
évidemment comme chez la plupart des
céphalopodes moderne apparemment c'est
la femelle qui est plus grosse que le
mal ils ont fait l'hypothèse que chez
les ammonites c'était pareil donc ils
ont pris le parti dans ce documentaire
de faire les mâles plus petit que les
femelles en parlant de ça
le tyrannosaure le fameux tyrannosaure
pareil un truc que j'attendais dans ce
documentaire que j'aurais bien aimé voir
mais qui ne s'est pas produit ben c'est
justement de voir les mâles plus petit
que les femelles mais ça encore c'est le
je crois que c'est l'épisode suivant si
je ne m'abuse voire même c'est l'épisode
3 mais là pour l'instant pour l'instant
tout ce qu'on a donc c'est un mâle
tyrannosaure alors le mali les îles et
chang qui quoi il est balèze il est bien
gras donc c'est ce qui est en lien en
face qui est à 6 s'alignent bien avec
l'idée qu'on se fait maintenant des
tyrannosaures ce n'était pas tellement
des maigrichon les tyrannosaures il
était bien bien en chair donc maintenant
les gens s'accordent enfin les
spécialistes des tyrannosaures
s'accordent à dire que tyrannosaurus rex
était plutôt fat coi plutôt gras bien en
chair donc moi ça me va très bien le et
là on nous montre donc encore une fois
un mal qui prend soin de ses petits donc
encore une fois un soin parental chez
tyrannosaure bon comme n'y a pas de
preuve pour ou contre ça on a le droit
de faire ce qu'on veut encore une fois
mais comme j'ai dit lassé on est déjà en
overdose dès le premier épisode on est
déjà presque en overdose de
comportements complexes de déplacement
en troupeau de soins parentaux et de
parades nuptiales hyper sophistiqué donc
donc là c'est ça faisait plaisir en fait
de voir un tyrannosaure qui s'occupe de
ses petits même si c'est pas
spécialement nouveau on est bien
d'accord il ya même un moment où il les
envoie chier ces petits je me suis dit
ah bah enfin on nous montre un truc un
peu différents donc
c'est déjà dès le premier épisode en
fait on sent qu'il va y avoir des
grandes lignes directrices pendant le
documentaire et que
et que tout ça est motivé par l'idée de
montrer une image moderne des dinosaures
une image où les dinosaures sont très
actifs comme les oiseaux avec des
comportements complexes et c est moi
j'aurais bien aimé voir un peu plus
aussi dans ce documentaire quelqu'un me
dire à un moment mais ma gueule être
intelligent ces mammifères au sens
strict enfin s'attendre à ce que tous
les animaux comme ça soit intelligent
c'est hyper mammifères au sens strict je
me rappelle avoir vu un documentaire
quand j'étais gamin qui était racontée
en fait par un adulte et un enfant
l'adulte étant seul ricciardo wen rien
que ça tintin en
est donc là donc l'enfant disait ah mais
ils ont des tout petits cerveaux c'est
ça devait être vraiment des débiles et c
est la richarde owen évidemment dans
toute sa prestance victorienne et la
terreur de son regard lui dit mais tu es
tellement mammifères au sens strict et
le gamin il fait quoi mais si tu pense
qu'avoir un gros cerveau c'est la seule
chose d'important dans la vie bah ouais
les gars de la vie entière 3 milliards
3,8
milliards d'années d'évolution se sont
faits avec un cerveau tout petit l'être
humain c'est une exception veut dire
avoir un gros cerveau ça n'a pas
d'importance et les comportements
complexes va évidemment vouloir dire que
un gros cerveau égale comportement
complexe ça veut dire gros cerveau égale
intelligence et on pourrait discuter à
propos de ça pendant des milliers
d'années mais bon on n'a que ça on n'a
que la taille du cerveau si vous voulez
et quelques quelques traces fossiles
pour pouvoir un ferrer ou il faire
l'hypothèse de comportements complexes
bon ben je veux dire en l'absence de
preuves de comportements complexes et
sachant que la plupart des dinosaures
avaient de toute façon avec eux toute la
totalité des dinosaures avait un cerveau
ridiculeusement petit par rapport à leur
taille c'est pas vilain de dire qu'ils
avaient des comportements simples c'est
pas méchant c'est pas c'est pas
faux vous faut se sent lever cette idée
de la tête que forcément s'ils ont eu un
succès évolutif à une période donnée
c'est forcément qu'il était intelligent
voilà et même si on a très envie de leur
donner des comportements complexes parce
qu'on les aime beaucoup et qu'on
aimerait bien les voir se comporter un
peu plus comme des chiens et des chats
ben non non non non tyrannosaurus rex
c'était 7 tonnes de viande commandé par
un cerveau grand comme ça et il ya et je
veux dire quand vous avez des quand vous
devez déjà coordonné 7 tonnes de
matières bahia ça vous reste plus
beaucoup de masse de cerveau pour avoir
du comportement complexe quoi c'est tout
c'est simple comme équation il reste
plus beaucoup de neurones une fois que
vous avez dédié un certain paquet de
neurones à la coordination motrice il
reste plus grand chose pour sachant
qu'en plus le cerveau de t-rex il ya
tout ça mais il ya ça de la golf actif
donc à tous à 2
pour renifler ce qui est d'ailleurs bien
retranscrit dans le documentaire pour le
coup il a reniflé une carcasse de très
très loin là car je crois que c'est la
carcasse de la tortue qu'on voit là
c'est certainement une arqués l'on
approche par an
mais voilà c'est très joli et c'est pas
vilain de dire que certains dinosaures
avaient des comportements simples et
c'est pas et surtout c'est c'est pas
méchant et c'est pas non scientifiques
non plus je veux dire il ya une vraie
base scientifique pour pouvoir dire que
les certains dinosaures devait avoir un
comportement simple typiquement les
sauropodes typiquement les grands
théropodes des machins qui ont plusieurs
tonnes de viande à coordonner avec un
tout petit cerveau bon bah je veux dire
il n'y a pas là il ya juste pas la
matière qu'il faut là où il faut pour
qu'ils aient un comportement complexe
les oiseaux modernes ont un très gros
cerveau et les oiseaux qu'on considère
traditionnellement comme un peu teubé
genre les poules les canards et les
autruches ben ce sont les trucs qui
ressemblait le plus aux dinosaures ce
sont les oiseaux qui ont les plus petits
cerveaux donc faux pas faut pas avoir
honte de dire des fois oui cet animal
avait un comportement tout à fait simple
en l'absence de preuves c'est en tout
cas plus judicieux plus parcimonieux de
dire que cet animal avait un
comportement simple donc c'est pour cela
que je passe je veux je veux bien si
vous voulez là je prends mon temps parce
que je sais que j'ai déjà fini la
première partie de la delà de la review
et que la plupart des gens n'iront même
pas jusque là là jusqu'à ce moment-là de
la vidéo mais voilà je veux prendre le
temps vraiment d'exprimer pourquoi je
pense que montrer des comportements
complexes tout le temps c'est un
problème à mon avis c'est un problème du
non on efface la diversité d'une
diversité comportementale possible et de
deux bah c'est pas la science elle dit
aussi elle dit comportement complexe
parce que faut comparer les dinosaures
aux oiseaux qui ont des comportements
complexes mais la science elle dit aussi
des dinosaures il n'avait pas un si gros
cerveau que ça ait une fois soustraits
la matière pour la coordination motrice
et les fonctions de base il reste plus
beaucoup de matière cérébrale il va ce
plus beaucoup de neurones pour la
complexité comportementale quoi et c'est
pour ça que je dis que dès l'épisode à
là on est abreuvé de comportements
complexes à base de soins parentaux à
base de deux parades nuptiales est à
base de déplacement en troupeau en meute
en ce que vous voulez
ça aurait été bien de montrer quelque
chose de différent pour une fois c'est
justement maintenant que maintenant
qu'on nous a fait cette phrase là dans
jurassic park en nous disant parce qu'en
1993 c'était surprenant de voir des
dinosaures s'est déplacé en troupeau à
l'écran ou sur le grand écran tu vois
donc maintenant qu'on a eu cette phrase
tire-larmes de il se déplace en troupeau
et la fameuse
le fameux passage ou s'imaginer que les
velociraptor était trop bête pour ouvrir
des portes et on les voit ouvrir des
portes bon ben ça y est on les a eus nos
dinosaures intelligent et nos dinosaures
avec des comportements complexes et
depuis jurassic park on a que ça donc ça
aurait été bien du coup maintenant de
faire peut-être un peu machine arrière
là dessus et 10 rebonds bas attendait
maintenant on va vous montrer une vraie
diversité de comportements j'arrête de
radoter vous le savez que je radote
pourquoi vous jouez les surpris comme ça
épisode 2 le désert donc on va commencer
par le commencement et j'ai envie de
dire par le plus évident alors les
sauropodes qui font des bouboules j'en
ai déjà parlé moi ça me choque pas plus
que ça je le dirai après tout
effectivement les oiseaux modernes ont
des fois des bouboules voilà là en plus
ils passent leur temps à expliquer que
les bouboules sont connectés au sac
aérien des vertèbres donc bon bah
pourquoi pas je le dire on a le droit
alors je sais que faut s'il vous plaît
avait pointé du doigt le fait qu'il
fallait pas confondre ça gueulait
rayssac aérien et je suis d'accord mais
bon pourquoi je veux dire là on est on
est en train de parler d'un machin qui a
déjà un coût de 15 mètres de long je
veux dire pourquoi pas pourquoi pas des
sacs aérien qui serait vachement plus
grand que ce qu'on imaginait il n'y a
pas de raison il n'y a pas de raison moi
je pense je suis je suis d'accord avec
la proposition que les sacs aériens
pouvaient se gonfler et c'est à dire
après tout la présence des sacs aérien
dans le coup des sauropodes c'est c'est
quand même une occurrence assez
particulière c'est quand même une
occurrence qu'on a du mal à expliquer
même si dans déjà dans le trailer
j'avais fourni des explications mais
c'est quand même quelque chose qu'on a
du mal à expliquer etc des sacs aérien
qui était quand même vachement grand et
on a que la partie préservée dans l'os
parce qu'après on sait pas quel point
ces sacs aérien se répandait dans la
chair donc je sais pas c'est pas ça qui
m'a choqué le coût des bouboules ça m'a
pas choqué le bruitage associés aux
boules m'a plutôt emmerder parce que
c'est vraiment un bruitage 2 cartonne
chez
pourquoi pourquoi vous avez un animal
gigantesque avec des sacs aérien qui lui
donne un coffre d'enfer et au lieu de
lui faire faire
[Musique]
vous lui faites faire
c'est dommage c'est dommage quoi la date
aurait pu envoyer un de ses pattes et
quand elle le dira niveau infra basses
la bon
bon bref
andy murray au russe quoi bon
[Musique]
peut-être un peu trop convenue j'avoue
aller admettons faut voir un sauropode
faire un son de basse c'est peut-être un
peu trop convenue mais bon ça aurait été
cool à s'arrêter crawl là où je suis pas
d'accord par contre du tout mais alors
genre du tout du tout du tout du tout
bon bah ces comportements complexes une
fois de plus on les voit se battre on
les voit se battre on les voit se
foutent sur la gueule on les voit se
dresser sur leurs pattes de derrière se
tenir comme des kangoo avec leur queue
et se [ __ ] sur la tronche enfin je
veux dire la la physique sait même pas s
que l'actuel pouvait soutenir le poids
du corps est ce que les pattes non c'est
là il ya juste là le mach à s'effondre
sur lui même là normalement et il n'y a
pas à tortiller du cul le moindre coût
c'est à dire déjà déjà se battre coup
contre coup pour les girafes c'est hyper
dangereux nous on se rend pas compte
parce qu'on fait pas la taille d'une
girafe mais les girafes quand elle se
bat là coup contrecoup à se donner des
coups avec leurs longues tête et leur
leurs cornes sur leur tête déjà ça vu la
taille des animaux une fois de plus les
grands animaux sont faibles comparés à
leur taille déjà là elles prennent
d'énormes risques imaginez maintenant à
sauropodes ça c'est un dreadnought us
c'est pas là ils ont été malins je les
ai vus là les ai vus la faire se
dérouler ce combat dans le désert
pourquoi il se déroule dans le désert ce
combat 1 là je vous voilà pourquoi il se
déroule dans le désert ben parce que
dans le désert y'a rien et quand il ya
rien n'y a pas d'échelle on se rend pas
compte la de la taille c'est exactement
ce que je disais entre ailleurs on se
rend pas compte de la taille mais là en
gros un être humain il arrive même pas
au genou du dre de lotus là le genou il
est là je vous fait apparaître la souris
juste le temps là le genou il est là est
un être humain il arriva à peine là un
être humain il est plus petit que le
fémur d'un dreadnought us
donc
c'est juste pour vous donner à l échelle
l'échelle parce que évidemment là ils
sont malins ils ont fait se passer ça
dans le désert les dreads lotus il bouge
pas au ralenti vous savez généralement
quand on veut donner l'impression de
gigantisme à l'écran ont fait bouger les
choses au ralenti hélas les dreads lotus
il bouge pas au ralenti bouger à vitesse
normale bbbbb m et il arriva il se
mettre sur la tronche et comme ya aucune
idée de la taille des choses autour
d'eux puisqu'il ya que des dreads lotus
et le désert du coup ça nous semble
normal de les voir se mettre sur la
tronche comme ça c'est pas normal là ce
qui se passe à l'écran c'est un truc de
tarés qui est en train de se passer à
l'écran là là vous avez des colosses de
la nature en train de se mettre des
coups qui sont pas capables d'encaisser
normalement donc là ils ont été malins
j'ai bien vu ce qu'ils ont fait mais
voilà dans sa salle a définitivement pas
pris sur moi et c'est dallas durant
cette fameuse scène qu'on voit le le
sauropodes s'écrouler à terre et là ils
auraient dû juste mais s'écraser comme
crêpes quoi tellement il est lourd
normalement je veux dire on parle brain
lotus ça fait ils nous disent 40 tonnes
mais on a des estimations jusqu'à 60
tonnes de dredd note us jeudi 60 tonnes
sur deux sur la terre ferme on n'a
jamais vu ça non mais jamais vu ça à un
éléphant ça fait douze tonnes maximum 12
tonnes maximum 1 le plus gros éléphant
qu'on n'a jamais pesé faisait 12 tonnes
pas l'éléphant moyens l'éléphant moyens
et fait 6 tonnes
donc 12 tonnes maximum pour un éléphant
déjà 20 tonnes c'est déjà le double là
on parle de 40 tonnes le double du
double
et on veut me faire croire déjà qu'un
éléphant ça peut même pas courir
tellement c'est fragile un éléphant ça
peut même pas courir tellement c'est
fragile ça peut même pas avoir c'est et
ça essaye autant que possible un
éléphant de n'avoir qu'une seule jambe
levée à la fois quand ça marche
tellement c'est lourd déjà un éléphant
et là vous voulez me faire croire que
ces machins pouvait se dresser sur leurs
pattes de derrière sans s'effondrer sur
eux mêmes le world trade center
non non ça la live c'est pareil c'est
comme les ptérosaures où ils ont rouvert
les vannes ils ont dit allez on va
démontrer super actif et super machin
non ces machins
justement c'est là qu'il fallait montrer
de la diversité pour comportementale
montrer les sauropodes l'an un peu
placide un peu tombé mais en même temps
encore une fois à quoi ça sert d'être
intelligent quand tu fais 60 tonnes à
quoi ça sert c'est c'est aussi ça qu'il
faut dire aux gens qui pour quoi tu veux
être intelligent tu fais déjà 60 tonnes
tu ne sers à rien le moindre le moindre
truc qui essayent de t'attaquer tu lui
mets un coup de patte comme ça ils
s'envolent à 4km boom
mais pas ce que je dis bien c'est de la
force par rapport à la taille parce
qu'une pâte qui fait 15 tonnes et qui
vous met une latte évidemment vous vous
envolez c'est de la force par rapport à
la taille que je parle quand je dis
qu'ils sont faibles
donc voilà on est sur l'exemple typique
du ils ont voulu de trop en mettre en
fait ils ont voulu mettre trop de
comportements complexes et là je
trouvais que c'était là j'ai vraiment
trouvé que c'était très dommageable pour
la cohérence générale du truc c'est
d'autant plus dommageable pour la
cohérence générale du truc qu'on a un
autre titanosaures qui revient dans le
dernier épisode et eux ils font pas les
bouboules et ils font pas le combat ils
font aussi une parade nuptiale
évidemment mais ils font pas les
bouboules et ils font pas le combat
donc donc en plus sage est un petit
froid sur la cohérence générale du truc
quoi parce que c'est tout la même
famille normalement c'est ces dinosaures
tous les dinosaures à long cou qu'on
nous montre à partir dans ce
documentaire appartient à la famille des
tyrannosaures le mono ni cus le moan
n'accuse je sais pas pourquoi il a
énervé plein de monde moi je le trouve
trop cute il est trop bien avec son
petit il a un petit masque de chouettes
effraies il est vraiment trop qu on
verra quel est le problème avec money
money cus alors j'avoue c'est pas
monique us en fait à qui est représentée
à l'écran c'est chou ya six ans ils
disent que c'est monique us mais en
réalité le petit alva réseau riddla ceux
qui ont un seul douala sur les doigts
sur les mains le petit alvaré the ride
qui est pleinement adapté à la vie au
crépuscule et pendant la nuit qui avait
des grands yeux et qui avaient des
oreilles d oreille interne est
exactement comme celle d'un
d'un d'une chouette
c'est shufu ya c'est pas monique us ça
je suis d'accord donc en fait si vous
partez du principe que c'est pas monique
us mais que c'est chouïa ça marche
vachement mieux
il ya beaucoup il ya encore une fois
c'est faux s'il vous plaît qui avait
fait la remarque que
qu'il aurait dû avoir les oreilles
asymétrique s'il avait un masque de
chouettes effraies c'est pas faux mais
alors avant de prouver que la symétrie
d'un crâne fossile et est due à une
réelle un réel truc biologique et pas
juste à la déformation ça va être
compliqué c'est à dire que même si tu
trouves akram un crâne ainsi betrix ça
veut pas dire que c'est pas la
déformation qu'il l'a rendu asymétrique
donc ça va être compliqué a démontré ce
genre de choses mais enfin je dirais à
propos de la proposition graphique est
en lien avec un mode de vie nocturne
et ce mode de vie nocturne est en lien
avec le fossile de chevreuil acquis et
dont on a découvert qu'il avait des
grands yeux et qu'ils avaient des
oreilles adapté à
comme les chouettes en fait adapté à
l'audition nocturne adapté en fait
finalement une adaptation à compenser
pour l'absence de lumière c'est à dire
avec un sens de l'ouïe hyper développé
pour compenser l'absence de lumière le
seul problème c'est que du coup chouïa
on le voit alors on voit que les ombres
sont rasante quand il est à l'écran
chouïa mais on le voit pas de nuit ce
qui est dommage du coup ça aurait été
plus logique effectivement de le montrer
en train de de chasse et de nuit ça
aurait été peut-être plus logique de le
montrer avec des vrais youtube de
chouettes du coup bas comme on avait
parlé sur le trailer avec le
velociraptor
des vrais yeux de chouettes bien rouge
ça aurait été ça aurait été intéressant
mais voilà c'est s'est basé sur la
chouette effraie donc ce design et moi
je le trouve super cute et ce petit
alvarezsauridés ce petit mot nonick us
il est très bien mais encore encore
faut-il évidemment moi j'ai fait juste
fait dans ma tête j'ai fait bois annoncé
chouïa puis après ils ont dit ces mots
ni que je fais non c'est chaud bouillant
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans ma tête je
veux dans mon jeu shui donc on nous
montre une fois de plus de raptor
chasser en meute et évidemment on
ils nous ont fait une petite vidéo
annexe pour nous expliquer que
pour nous expliquer que évidemment la
chasse en meute les empreintes parallèle
les caisses qui a d'autres les fossiles
retrouvés tous ensemble et puis les
chasseurs moderne qui chassent en meute
les oiseaux modernes qui chassent en
meute alors c'est pas si répandue que ça
en réalité comme je l'aï dit plus tôt
donc on nous dit la chasse en meute b si
c'est possible
moi j'ai fait une vidéo de 45 minutes
quand même où j'explique que ouais c'est
possible mais bon c'est quand même pas
probable
donc je vous invite à aller voir si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur pourquoi je
pense et pourquoi a de l'avis général
faudrait peut-être y aller mollo sur les
raptors qui chassent en meute je vous
renvoie vers cette vidéo qui fait déjà
45 minutes je vais pas repasser 45
minutes où elle fait 1h30 je sais plus
enfin bref je vais pas repasser entre 45
minutes et une heure trente à
réexpliquer pourquoi les raptor ne
devrait pas chasser en meute qui a il ya
plein de raisons fossiles pour laquelle
ce serait pas le cas et surtout basse
est basé sur une façon l'idée de base en
fait c'était c'était on a retrouvé des
raptor au-dessus d'années de montauzon
autour d'aden moteur donc d'aider nonick
us autour d'anne et de motos hors
fossilisés et puis les mecs on dit alors
ça pourrait être pour des raisons
taphonomie qu mais nous on a décidé de
croire qu'ils chasser en meute c'est la
conclusion de l'article pour jeudi à
partir de là c'est quand même hein c'est
quand même une base assez chancelante
pour dire les raptors chasser en meute
mais là pour le coup on nous montre
encore des raptor chasser en meute et à
quasiment chaque épisode on va y avoir
loire on va aussi avoir le droit à
certains drôme et aux oreilles des qui
se balade tout seul quand même ça va
arriver at rossi raptor ya trop si
raptor convoi chasser tout seul à un
moment donc quand même ça c'est de
suffisamment notable pour être pour être
mentionnée mais ouais j'aurais bien aimé
pour une fois qu'on nous explique du
coup bah c'est un velociraptor et il est
tout seul et il va se battre contre un
proto ceratops était bien ça ne nous
montrait le le fameux combat
velociraptor proto ceratops parce que ça
c'est les preuves évidentes qu'il était
tout seul quand il s'est battu contre ce
proto ceratops parce que s'il avait été
à plusieurs bains soit le velociraptor
en question ne serait pas mort en se
battant avec le proto ceratops soit il
serait mort en se battant contre le
proto ceratops mais du coup les autres
on aurait quand même profité pour
bouffer la carcasse du proto ceratops là
on a le velociraptor et le proto
ceratops en train de se tuer l'un à
l'autre et qui sont restés comme ça sans
bouger sans changer c'est quand même une
preuve très positif que les velociraptor
ne le chassent et pas en doute bref en
tout cas le design du vélociraptor est
très bien mais ça je l'avais déjà
mentionné dans la dans le dans le
trailer le design du vélociraptor et
enfin respectés voilà long museau très
fin gracile anatomy très gracile petite
taille etc etc la façon dont ils se
déplacent dont nous la façon dont les
velociraptor se déplace je sais qu'à un
moment on en voit c'est dans l'épisode
suivant je crois on en voit se déplacer
sur une falaise et il se pète la gueule
et ils cèdent un peu de leur zèle
justement là pour amortir la chute et
tout ça et puis là il ya plein de levée
de boucliers pour dire ah c'est pas
possible de survivre à une chute
pareille alors sur le coup je me suis
dit je me suis dit ça je me suis dit
[ __ ] une chute pareille en ayant les
au creux parce que le raptor évidemment
il avait les au creux d une chute
pareille avec les au creux quand même
ils auraient dû ce péter une guibole bah
oui mais une chute pareille avec les
autres eux tu te fais moi mal en pétant
la gueule quand même justement c'est
encore une fois en partant du principe
que les velociraptor raptor était déjà
de relativement petite taille et qu'en
plus il était relativement léger
ils sont plus solides par leur taille
dont ils peuvent oui puis en plus on les
voit quand même utiliser leur zèle pour
amortir la chute donc c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal du coup ça ça suggère
quand même une fonction des ailes bien
que les velociraptor savait pas volé en
plus donc c'est intelligent niveau
narratif c'est ce et narratif mais sans
le dire voilà les shows don't tell le
fameux donc non je suis plutôt je suis
plutôt d'accord avec je suis plutôt en
paix avec la chute des raptors mais je
ne sais pas dans cet épisode là c'est
après
mai et puis de manière générale si je
peux commenter sur le fait qu'ils aient
fait une seule chaîne youtube secondaire
pour commenter sur les choix qu'ils ont
fait pendant le documentaire c'est très
intéressant je ne dis pas le contraire
c'est très intéressant d'avoir fait
avoir pris cette initiative
par contre faut pas que ça serve comme
excuse 1 c'est à dire que si dans le
documentaire vous montrer un truc qui a
une logique complètement fauqué et on va
en parler il ya des trucs qui marchent
pas notamment notamment le fameux car
nos torts et ses petits bras bleus la
sas à une logique complètement pété et
même dans la vidéo où il explique
exactement pourquoi ils ont pris ce
choix de faire incarne hauteur avec des
petits bras bleus ça la logique elle
reste complètement pété parce que ils
vous disent ah bah vous voyez là le pan
il a deux il a des grandes plumes bleus
et puis vous voyez le cerf il a des
grands bois et puis des rachats oui mais
là le carnot tort il a des petits bras
de merde oui mais le carnot tort il a
quand même une articulation qui encore
fonctionnel et touba oui ce qui n'enlève
rien au fait il ya quand même deux
autres celle des poignets et celle des
coudes qui fonctionne pas dire faites
juste la paix avec ce le fait que cet
organe soit trop fier c'est tout je
dirais puis qu'il y reste oui il reste
une petite articulations qui fonctionne
encore histoire que le bras soit pas
constamment plaqué contre le reste du
corps et que ça se mette pas un loisir
sous les aisselles quoi voilà il peut et
qui peut battre un peu des bras il sera
peuvent faire prendre l'air pour pâques
et du moisi qui pousse quoi ça tient
bon bref donc faut pas que ça serve des
excuses donc si il faut que j'aille voir
tous les contenus tous les tweets et
tous les machins pour comprendre ce
qu'ils ont essayé de faire dans le docu
c'est que le docu a fait un truc de
travers voilà faut faut quand même être
honnête là dessus c'est normalement on
n'a pas à aller voir ailleurs si les
informations y sont voilà quand les
informations sont bien distillé donc là
en l'occurrence ils ont fait ça c'est un
contenu en plus donc c'est intéressant
et je suis d'accord et je les ai vus
et je les ai vu avec plaisir d'ailleurs
y'a pas de soucis mais faut pas que ça
serve d'excusé non plus les raptors qui
chassent en meute ça fait quand même un
moment qu'on devrait avoir remis ça en
question et qu'on devrait montrer ça
avec parcimonie dans les documentaires
alors il ya une scène qui se passe sur
un lac où on voit un troupeau une fois
de plus de sauropodes arriver et là
c'est un très très bon exemple de
pourquoi les explications qui sont
trouvés à côté surtout il heures et
youtube sont pas vraiment des excuses
c'est que ce qu'ils ont pour dire qu'il
y avait des sauropodes des titanosaures
à l'époque dans le désert de gobi c'est
pas des squelettes il ya aucun n'ose ils
ont une empreinte de pas elle est très
jolie elle est très design au stick
c'est parfait mais ils ont une empreinte
de pas pourquoi avoir mis un troupeau
par exemple voilà on pouvait pas nous
montrer bah voilà ce sauropodes il est
là il est tout seul il est peut-être en
train de mourir c'est ça se trouve il
est peut-être elle est peut-être au bord
du désespoir j'en sais rien et vias à ce
point d'eau parce que c'est ça c'est la
dernière chose qu'il raccrochera sa
survie j'en sais rien ça aurait été un
truc intéressant à voir ce sauropodes il
est tout seul et il est dans la merde
maintenant on a une empreinte on vous
montre un troupeau alors là il ya les
tares bozor aussi les tares bozor ils
sont très intéressants j'ai beaucoup
aimé parce que l'état reposant on nous
les montrent en train de glander et ça
c'est bien pour une fois les caisses
carnivores ne sont pas représentés comme
des espèces de monstres stupide qui ne
pensent qu'à bouffer et ça c'est cool ça
c'est cool ça j'aime
tartan du jurassique world un fallen
kingdom tu as entendu tu as entendu les
carnivores ne sont pas forcément des
machines à tuer les carnivores ne sont
pas des monstres ce sont juste des
animaux ils mangent quand ils ont faim
et ils arrêtent de manger quand ils
n'ont plus faim tu as entendu
mais bon je pense que dans jurassic
vente dominion on va encore y avoir le
droit aux carnivores monstrueux qui
cherchent à boucher à tout prix
d'ailleurs dans la bande annonce on y
voit déjà vachement bien les carnivores
qui cherchent à bouffer à tout prix à
bouffer le héros à tout prix 1 le mec il
se barre à moto il ya le reste du
village qui est là à les regarder en
train de courir les raptors et c'est le
mec à moto qu'ils veulent c'est le héros
qui veulent ils sont héros fort il son
héros bord
[Rires]
bref donc donc déjà voyait les
carnivores sont pas représentés comme
des justes des monstres bête et
assoiffés de sang donc ça c'est bien et
on voit un moment cette scène où le tard
bozor s'avance vers le trou d'eau et en
fait on voit les herbivores qui juste
ces cartes est alors déjà ça fait déjà
vachement western tu vois d'arrivée le
de voir arriver le tarbes leuthard
brothers pour ça que je dis il est beau
ce documentaire parce qu'il ya des mises
en scène absolument absolument
magnifique il ya des décors des tout ça
c'est très beau et on voit donc ce que
tarbes aux heures à arriver au trou
d'eau un peu l'ofrou il me regarde tous
donc ça fait très western il arrive au
trou d'eau hybois et les cas et les
arbitres bord du court est avec une
distance de sécurité autour mais ne s'en
vont pas ne s'enfuit pas et ça c'est
pareil ça peut faire grincer des dents
mais en réalité dans la nature bas quand
vous avez soif bas vous avez soif
et on peut le dire on va pas dire que
les que les loups sont stupides d'aller
boire dans une eau à fêter infestée de
crocodiles dans le serengeti c'est juste
que si vous comprenez pas pourquoi
pourquoi ce que nous
va boire dans une eau infestée dans une
eau dégueulasse et infestée de
crocodiles c'est parce que vous n'avez
jamais connu la soif vous êtes des
primates vous êtes une espèce tropicale
vos ans et enfin vous êtes un primate
vous en plus vous êtes homo sapiens vous
n'avez probablement jamais connu le
besoin enfin tout cas si vous avez un
ordinateur devant vous en train de
regarder cette vidéo ou un téléphone
c'est vous n'avez probablement jamais
connu besoin au point de devoir aller
boire dans une eau infestée de
crocodiles et dégueulasse voilà vous
n'avez jamais eu soif là en l'occurrence
ces animaux ils ont [ __ ] de soif et
donc même s'il tarde bozor il arrive
justice écarte mais s'en vont pas mais
bon ça c'est ça c'est pour le coup c'est
un vrai comportement
réaliste que j'aime beaucoup justement
ils n'ont pas montré genre à la panique
et puis le tard bozor qui essaye de leur
courir après alors qu'il est venu pour
boire à la base et puis mais qui essaye
quand même de boucher parce que c'est un
carnivore et
ça c'est beau ça c'est beau et c'est
couillu comme comme choix c'est bien
bon et puis encore une fois bas dans ce
désert tous les comportements sont
complexes je veux pas tous les relevés
on a une scène avec les ptérosaures vous
justement là c'est la fameuse scène avec
les ptérosaures qui seront qui se
comporte comme dessert donc c'est pareil
je vais pas m'arrêter dessus épisode 3
l'eau douce
freshwater en anglais on m'avait promis
que le tyrannosaure ne réussirait pas
dans le documentaire qu'il ne réagissait
que dans la bande annonce
c'était un mensonge c'était un mensonge
il rugit le tyrannosaure il au logis et
pas qu'une fois
donc encore une fois je vais pas
m'étaler dessus mais bon on a le droit
de faire rugir les tyrannosaures si on
veut le truc c'est que le rugissement
c'est vraiment un truc chez les
mammifères c'est un truc de grand félin
donc un truc du des félins du genre
pantera lions et tigres typiquement donc
déjà chez les mammifères faire des gros
son
c'est un truc qui est rare donc là le
tyrannosaure on s'attend quand même plus
à ce qu'il faisait des gros gargouillis
plutôt que des rugissements mais bon ce
sens on n'a pas de cordes vocales de
t-rex pour dire si oui ou non ils en
étaient capables donc aller va pour le
régissent mans ce qui m'a beaucoup plus
déranger avec le t-rex c'est encore une
fois perpétuellement en chaleur le
bouzin quoi le dira d'eux et a alors le
t-rex c'est à mal c'est un vieux mâles
et donc il rencontre une femelle
évidemment la femelle est plus petit
bing perdu
alors ça alors évidemment on s'est
justifié par le fait que la femelle est
plus jeune et que lui c'est un vieux
mâles donc évidemment il est plus gros
bon c'est un peu s'écarter du fait que
chez les tyrannosaures la croissance
était déterminé pour autant que je sache
enfin si elle était indéterminée s'était
pas de beaucoup à la fin je veux dire ça
ça faisait un plateau qui montaient
légèrement tu vois plutôt un symptôme
tic qu'autre chose quoi
donc allez admettons que la croissance
était pas tout à fait déterminée chez
les tyrannosaurus enfin pareil ça aurait
été intéressant de nous montrer en plus
ils l'ont fait après pour les quarts nos
torts si ça que je comprends pas c'est
pour les carnot tort ils l'ont fait la
femelle plus gros que le mal alors que
là on n'a aucune preuve pour le coup
pour les carnot tort ils ont fait la
femelle plus rock lo mal alors qu'on a
pas de preuve pour le tyrannosaure on a
des preuves que les fumets que les
femelles étaient au moins plus robuste
sinon généralement plus rose que les
mâles mais là ils l'ont pas fait et donc
ils n'ont pas fait effectivement le coût
des femelles qui se battaient pour les
mâles ce qui aura été pour une fois
encore une fois une diversité de
comportements
qui aurait montré aussi des
comportements qu'on sait dont on sait
qu'ils ont plus arriver puisque on a des
traces de on a des traces de morsures
sur les notamment les crânes des
tyrannosaures mâles et femelles
donc les mâles et les femelles se
faisait mordre sur le visage donc
c'était c'était quelque chose qui était
qui n'était pas uniquement chez les
mâles pour le coup
donc là on en aurait eu on avait un
support on avait un support fossiles
pour un comportement qui aurait pour une
fois un peu changé bon bah non on a le
droit à monsieur rencontre madame donc
monsieur les plus petits que madame
monsieur mes plus grands que madame du
coup et donc monsieur tu sais pas
pourquoi c'est pas la saison de la
reproduction mais d'un seul coup il se
met en mode parade nuptiale et alors qui
plus est la parade nuptiale l'une des
parades nuptiales les plus les plus
dangereuses que j'ai jamais vu là pour
le coup je l'avais dit là dans le
trailer les comportements dangereux
pendant les parades nuptiales ça me
dérange pas mais alors là sachant qu'en
plus on nous a pas dit que c'était la
saison des amours le dire ils essayent
de se suicider le t-rex en montrant sa
gorge à la femelle
donc on nous précise pas qu'on ait
pendant la saison des amours d t-rex
d'un seul coup il rencontre une femelle
tu crois qu'ils vont se battre mais en
fait non alors ça c'est un truc
classique un collègue qui avait fait un
bingo tu sais d un bingo des
documentaires de sur les dinosaures et
qui est il rencontre un autre t-rex tic
ils vont se battre tic
ah non en fait ils vont faire l'amour
tic parade nuptiale complexe tic
chassent en meute
et c'est donc là il y avait il y avait
le bingo du documentaire sur les
dinosaures et là tu avais toutes les
cases d'un seul coup qui est
donc ce bon t-rex il rencontre une
femelle c'est pas la période des amours
il lui montre sa gorge et tu sais pas
comment ça finit en accouplements puis
là on est arrivé à l'épisode 3 on a déjà
vu plein de parades nuptiales etc donc
on commence un peu à en avoir on
commence un peu avoir l'habitude etc etc
donc effectivement et puis et puis il ya
le fait alors j'avais souligné le fait
que les écailles sur le t-rex là sur le
visage du t-rex sur la sur le nez est
absolument magnifique et ça c'est vrai
ça reste graphiquement beau je vais pas
répéter à tous les épisodes que que tous
les épisodes sont graphiquement beau
tout est magnifique
mais du coup ça manque de cicatrices
quand même sur son visage au t-rex parce
qu'on s'est quand même encore une fois
on a des preuves abondantes hyper
nombreuses que les t-rex se mordait la
tronche les uns les autres
des centaines de crâne littéralement de
t-rex qui ont été retrouvés enfin des
crânes ou fragment de crâne qui ont été
retrouvés avec des traces de morsures et
qu'est-ce qu'on a là bas on a des dénés
absolument immaculé y compris chez le
vieux t-rex qui a plein de cicatrices
par ailleurs donc ça c'est dommage ça
c'est dommage là il ya une belle
occasion manquée là de montrer justement
les cicatrices sur le nez du t-rex etc
fait intéressant pendant l'accouplement
t-rex ne se sert pas de ses bras donc
j'ai donné jeu quand je quand j'ai fait
pas quand j'ai parlé déjà tout à l'heure
et pendant le trailer du fait qu'il y
avait les petits bras du carneau tort et
que les gens essayer absolument de
trouver des fonctions à ses petits bras
même s'il en avait à l'évidence aucune
bombe à là pour le coup j'ai été très
satisfait là je plusse pousse-pousse
bleus vers le haut tout ça
le t-rex n'utilise pas ses petits bras
pendant l'accouplement ça je m'y
attendais je m'y attendais à ce qu'on
nous dise et là il utilise ses petits
bras pour agripper la femelle parce que
sinon ils risquent de tomber oui bien
sûr parce que tomber évidemment donc et
non ces genres ses petits bras qui vont
l'empêcher de tomber c'est là où je veux
en venir ce genre c'est ses petits bras
comme ça qui vont l'empêcher de tomber
et non ils gardent les petits bras comme
ça et puis ça couple tranquille on voit
la femelle s'accroupir je suis plutôt
une bonne idée pour représenter un
accouplement
ce qui me manquait un peu encore une
fois c'était peut-être le t-rex qui est
le mal qu'ils attrapent la femelle au
niveau de la nuque pour justement se
tenir ça ça aurait été intéressant à
montrer autoritaire intéressant à
montrer et ça aura été cohérent avec le
fait de mettre des grosses lèvres et des
grosses gencives sur la bouche du t-rex
justement comme ça ils ont montré
visuellement que il est aussi capable
d'attraper les choses délicatement un
parce que c'est pas parce qu'on a des
muscles qui permettent de broyer les os
qu'on va broyer les os à chaque fois
qu'on attrape un truc c'est pas vrai ça
donc ça ça aurait été intéressant de
voir justement le t-rex attraper la
nuque mais bon ça c'est pareil c'est un
comportement qui est assez spécifique
aux mammifères
oui je crois pas que les oiseaux fasse
tellement ça doit être tout à fait je
suis même sûr que les presque sûr que
les oiseaux ne le font pas mais en tout
cas ça aurait été intéressant à montrer
ces épisodes aussi où on a dénoté russe
alors des moquées russe qui a un museau
en forme de spatules bas comme les
oiseaux spatule du coût et du coup on
nous le représente dans l'eau alors
j'avais j'avais dit d'en montrer leur
dans la dans l'analyse du trailer mais
on n'a aucune preuve qui vivaient dans
l'eau et qui se nourrissait de
nourriture aquatique bah oui mais enfin
il a quand même le nez en forme de
spatules j'avoue
c'était quand même un gros indice dont
qu'ils ont je pense que je reviens sur
ma décision de dire qu'il n'y a pas de
raison de le représenter spécialement
dans l'os d'hénocq et russe en réalité
il y est pas mal du tout
juste un truc auquel la scène avec les
moustiques enfin la scène avec les
mouches et après il ya aussi la scène
avec les moustiques dans un épisode
d'après je crois que c'est l'épisode iv
où on voit des dinosaures se faire
emmerder par des mouches et les
moustiques ya même des bébés qui meurent
à un moment avec des mouches et des
moustiques et on les voit jamais se
rouler dans la boue mais ça je comprends
pas pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi on voit pas le le comportement
animal typique en réaction à des à une
infestation de parasites qui est se
rouler dans la boue alors j'imagine que
c'est pour pouvoir continuer à montrer
les belles plumes et les belles couleurs
des dinosaures mais c'est dommage c'est
un comportement tellement évident
pourquoi juste pourquoi donc là ouais je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup il ya au moins
deux scènes de tout le documentaire qui
aurait pu largement être évité
juste en montrant un comportement tout
bête qui est se rouler dans la boue pour
que la boue recouvre la peau pour que
l'on se sente plus embêté par les
mouches et les moustiques et la scène où
ceux qui me connaissent doivent attendre
c'est la scène du kids aco est luce en
afrique du sud quand il a quand il a
annoncé à l'écran dire afrique du sud et
là j'ai fait ils vont nous montrer des
trucs d'afrique du sud avant de montrer
des trucs d'afrique du sud pourtant y'a
rien crétacé fini au crétacé terminal
d'afrique du sud il n'y a rien donc je
me suis dit waouh l'afrique du sud
l'afrique du sud on va voir des trucs
d'afrique du sud
et puis là on voit inquiète zalko atlus
et il nous dit que cette enquête alcoa
plus et qui vient pondre en afrique du
sud de sanaa du fait mais de quoi
passer dinosaures en afrique du sud
étaient obligés de nous inventer à
quetzalcoatlus
surtout les ptérosaures on en a pas on
n'a quasiment pas en afrique du sud des
ptérosaures pourquoi pourquoi nous foute
raquette zalko atlus dans cette région
du monde j'ai pas compris j'ai beau
grand bruit on fait ce qu'on veut on
s'en fout
s'il ya pas de facile on fait ce qu'on
veut ça
bon et puis après après on comprend
qu'en fait on est à madagascar on n'est
pas vraiment en afrique du sud après un
problème c'est que le problème s'est
passé que ça se dit pareil quoi afrique
du sud sud de l'afrique voilà
mais on comprend après qu'on ait à
madagascar donc on n'est pas réellement
en afrique du sud surtout que enfin on
n'est pas réellement dans le sud de
l'afrique puis surtout que madagascar
avait déjà bien commencé à dériver du
continent à l'époque il me semble donc
puisqu'elle a été remportée avec l'inde
au loin des côtes africaines
donc bon en fait c'était le ct
madagascar puisqu'on voit masi à cazaux
russe et belzébuth faux épisode 4 ice
world le monde de la glace dont qui se
passe dans l'eau loin loin dans
l'hémisphère nord probablement en alaska
le plus bel épisode sans aucun doute
c'est le plus bel épisode de tous il est
visuellement il est incroyable donc
voilà il ya cette fameuse scène que
j'avais déjà commenté dans le trailer il
ya plein de scènes notamment avec les
ânes rose or celle où ils sont embêtés
par les moustiques pleine scène qui sont
tournés en islande donc de magnifiques
décors d'islande il ya la scène alors
j'avais cru que on voyait l'extinction
du crétacé de la faim crétacé se
reflétait dans l'oeil d'un dinosaure et
je m'étais dis ouah c'est beau c'est
poétique ces machins bon c'est pas ça
c'était pas ça c est un petit trop haute
idée qui chassent dans la forêt qui est
en feu en fait qui fait un peu comme
certains oiseaux de proie font
aujourd'hui en fait qui répand du cheveu
avec des braises ils attrapent des
brésil les transporte et il répond le
feu pour pouvoir attraper pour pouvoir
débusquer des proies et ça c'est un
comportement super intéressant à voir
dans un documentaire animé en fin d'un
documentaire jallet dinosaures enfin tu
vois hélas s'est justifié en disant bah
oui c'est un troodontidés et les trop
haute idée ils ont un gros cerveau
comparé aux autres dinosaures et là je
dis oui oui oui il l'a enfin il l'a
problème c'est qu'on est déjà à
l'épisode iv et on a vu tous les
dinosaures être intelligent et même des
trucs qui sont pas des dinosaures être
intelligent et là on voit là sa pointe
clairement du doigt le problème que je
souligne depuis tout à l'heure et je
radote et je le répète et tant pis ça se
sa pointe clairement du doigt le
problème le problème c'est que
maintenant que tu nous a montré que tous
les dinosaures étaient intelligents bas
voire trop dons intro dont il est en
train de naître supérieurement
intelligent parce qu'il utilise du feu
pour débusquer des proies et tout ça est
basse a aucun impact du coup parce que
c'est un comportement incroyable sa rage
le dire c'est un comportement hyper
hyper évoluer enfin hyper évoluer hyper
hyper spécialisés quand même
donc et en plus ça perd d'autant plus de
son impact que ce tron ont d'autres
idées qui est super intelligent l e est
un des seul dinosaure qui chassent tout
seul catherine chasse par mute
donc voilà mais c'est pour ça c'est pour
ça que je dis mais c'est dommage d'avoir
rendu tous les dinosaures intelligent
d'avoir rendu tous les dinosaures
hyperactif d'avoir attendu d'avoir rendu
tous les dinosaures
d'avoir donné des comportements
complexes à tous les dinosaures ce pour
ça que c'est dommage c'est parce que
quand on a dit non au sort pour lequel
on peut raisonnablement dire qu'il avait
des comportements complexes ben ça passe
complètement sous le radar du coup là on
est au quatrième épisode ça fait déjà
quatre ça fait déjà presque quatre
heures du coup plus de 3h30
ça fait plus de 3h30 qu'on nous sert des
3h15 du coup c'est 4 fois 40 donc j'ai
pas envie de faire le calcul je suis
fatigué ça fait un moment que je parle
déjà on va essayer d'éviter les maths
pour éviter que ce soit trop long de
cette vidéo donc ça fait déjà presque
quatre heures qu on nous abreuve de
comportement ahurissant de trucs de
prouesses de prouesses cognitives voit
la bombe à arriver à troodon qui est
trop donc ils transportent des braises
j'ai envie de dire c'est banal il se
chassent même pas en meute je suis
unique il est intelligent sur
ben voilà on a on aurait bien vu la
différence là du coup entre un sauropode
qui se contente de marcher tout droit et
de manger voilà et puis qui marchent en
troupeau ans
qui marche en troupeau mais de loin quoi
et puis qui et puis d'autres dinosaures
comme des ankylose or qui vivrait
réellement tout seul et puis d'autres
théropodes qui chasserait en groupe mais
qu'occasionnellement ou qui serait juste
en groupe mais que par
un peu comme les crocodiles voyait qui
chassera en groupe mais seulement par
opportunité quoi parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de proies donc à beaucoup de prédateurs
voilà on aurait pu nous montrer tout ça
et et nous montrer à la fin le troodon
qui chassent en meute qui étend qui
répand le feu qui tend une embûche et on
voit tous les trop au don d'un seul coup
courir vers une grosse proie pour
l'abattre et là au moins ça aurait été
nous montrer de la chasse en meute
parcimonieuse j'aurais quand même râler
mais au moins ça ne vous auraient montré
de la chasse en meute parcimonieuse et
ça nous aurait montré
vraiment le la diversité des
intelligences qu'on a au sein de ce seul
groupe qu'on appelle les dinosaures ça
nous aurait bien montrer là on aura tout
depuis les machins qui sont en mode
quasiment pilotage automatique les
sauropodes jusqu'à troodontidés qui sont
à la frontière
de d'un comportement evian quiberon là
en l'occurrence il aurait là avec le
transport des braises ils ont largement
pulvérisé la frontière du comportement a
bien on est bien d'accord mais voilà on
en est on aurait eu sept ce contraste
qui aurait eu du sens et puis là juste
vous pour vous montrer les packs irin
aux orres parce que quand j'ai raison
j'aime bien le montrer n'est pas kirin
aux orres ils ont bien les yeux avec une
pupille horizontale comme les chèvres
cela j'avais raison ce avait raison
j'avais raison par contre j'avais tort
ce n'était pas du tout un gros mais aux
orchidées bouffe c'est un ami konan uxo
russe je crois donc évidemment on peut
pas avoir raison tout le temps et enfin
l'épisode 5 la forêt de forest donc
l'épisode 5 ce qui a fait grincer des
dents la plupart des gens apparemment
basse et les tricératops mais les
tricératops qui traverse une grotte je
sais pas pourquoi ça a choqué en fait
c'est peut-être que alors je sais pas
c'est ce qui a choqué là dedans c'est
vrai que quand on les voit traverser la
grotte on voit les on voit que les corps
ne sont plus grosses que là ils sont
plus grandes que là que la grotte et du
coup ça donne vraiment à côté
est-ce que c'est magique là est ce que
c'est une corne fantôme qu'est ce qui se
passe donc c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression mais c'est l'effet de
perspective qui est juste pas très bien
fait pas très bien rendue je suppose
mais c'est vrai que là pour le coup ça
donne vraiment l'impression way que tu
as des animaux avec des ornementations
du crâne bien trop développé dans un
endroit beaucoup trop exigus en fait
donc et la scène n'arrête pas d'ailleurs
de vous montrer à quel point c'est
stupide de faire ça puisque ce petit là
le bébé à l'écran la manque de se faire
tuer au moins une quinzaine de fois
parce qu'ils sont dans le noir complet
donc en plus oui des animaux dans le
noir complet s'est pas exactement non
plus une très bonne idée de montrer des
animaux dans le noir complet puisque les
surtout des animaux dont le sens de
l'orientation était essentiellement
visuel comme les tris heures afin comme
les dinosaures de manière générale
excepté shufu ya en tout cas jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
c'était des animaux au sens de
l'orientation essentiellement visuel
donc c'est dommage de leurs privé ça
m'étonnerait en fait qui se seraient
privés d'un de leurs sens comme ça après
les voir marcher dans une grotte s'est
directement inspiré je pense des
éléphants puisque les éléphants sont
connus il ya certes il ya une population
d'éléphants on n'a pas non plus exagérer
la proéminence de ce comportement il ya
une population d'éléphants qui est connu
pour aller dans une grotte pour aller
manger le sel dans cette grotte parce
que les animaux ils ont besoin de celle
notamment dans les environnements sec
pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir garder l'eau à l'intérieur
de leur corps pour pas se déshydrater
puis ils ont besoin de sels minéraux de
manière générale je veux dire tous les
animaux ont besoin de sels minéraux et
notamment les arts vivants ont du mal à
trouver des sels minéraux dans les
plantes
donc ils vont s'abreuver en selle dans
les grottes en tout cas ces éléphants là
vont s'abreuver de sel dans les grottes
là on a des tricératops qui
contrairement aux éléphants les
éléphants notamment les adultes sont
quasiment aveugle et il se repère
essentiellement à l'odeur donc une fois
qu'un éléphant a laissé une marque
quelque part pour aller dans la grotte
c'est très facile pour les autres
éléphants de le suivre et ça sur
plusieurs années et en plus ces
éléphants on a un énorme cerveau
en taille absolue mais aussi en taille
relative et ils sont connus notamment
pour avoir une réelle vraie grosse
mémoire avoir une mémoire d'éléphant ce
n'est pas seulement un dicton c'est une
réalité les éléphants ont effectivement
une superbe mémoire une mémoire
gigantesque donc donc là on est
peut-être en train d'attribuer
effectivement attristera top c'est un
comportement un poil trop évolué pour
pour lui parce que là tricératops pour
le coup le si vous imaginez que la cre a
le crâne de tricératops fait cette
taille la collerette inclut le cerveau
il fait cette taille là donc encore une
fois ça laisse pas beaucoup de ça laisse
pas beaucoup de neurones
dédiée à l'intelligence et à la mémoire
notamment donc là à voir ses traits
ceratops effectué un pèlerinage dans le
noir complet ouais c'est vrai que ça
peut faire grincer des dents et l'ayant
déjà vu en fait connaissance et
histoires à propos des éléphants en fait
ça m'a pas choqué ça m'a plu ce qui m'a
plus choqué c'est l'utilisation de
glaise pas il utilise une sorte de boue
pour pour atténuer la
[Musique]
la toxicité des plantes qu'ils ingèrent
ce qui est une bonne idée en soi c'est
l'utilisation d'un créateur naturel en
fait mais est ce que c'est réellement
documentée dans le règne animal ça par
contre
je suis pas sûr s'ils l'ont fait c'est
que j'imagine ils l'ont ils l'ont vu
quelque part dans des années chez des
animaux moderne
après tout on sait que on sait que
beaucoup de dinosaure herbivore se
prenaient des gastros liszt dont je veux
dire c'est jeune c'est jamais qu'un sait
jamais exactement le même comportement
mais pour une autre raison ils n'ont pas
forcément à comprendre cette raison pour
le faire je ne pense pas que les animaux
comprennent qu'ils doivent manger des
gastros les animaux qui ont des gastros
lite ne comprennent pas qu'ils doivent
prendre des gastros lite pour digérer
c'est juste dans leur instinct de
bouffer un galet quoi c'est tout on voit
ça avec les plésiosaures d'ailleurs un
peu plus dans le premier épisode
ils ont juste l'instinct d'avaler des
gadins et un point c'est tout quoi mais
ils savent pas que c'est spécialement
indispensable pour digérer ils n'ont pas
le savoir du moins donc ouais là le
coude et tricératops dans la grotte
qu'elle pourrait ya le contre j'ai envie
de dire
le pour et le contre et c'est là
justement que le problème du
docu-fiction
pointe le bout de son nez j'aurais bien
aimé qu'on nous l'expliquent ce là pour
le coup j'aimerais bien qu'ils mettent
là sur leur chaîne youtube au moment où
georges i cette vidéo elle n'y est pas
mais j'aurais bien aimé qu'ils mettent
sur leur chaîne youtube une petite
explication concernant cette scène le
dinosaure bleus moi j'ai rien contre
personnellement c'est avec le bleu est
pas si commun même chez les oiseaux
surtout sur la totalité du corps mais on
les voit se déplacer en troupeau à la
limite à voir cette couleur bleue pareil
ça aura été bien avec une explication du
genre
cette couleur bleue est un avertissement
qui montrent qu'ils sont toxiques et en
fait c'est pas ils sont pas réellement
toxiques mais c'est juste qu'ils font
semblant d'être toxiques là c'est pareil
ça aurait été un truc assez assez unique
voyez dans chez les dinosaures lioret de
montrer dire en fait cette couleur bleue
elle est là pour que justement on les
voit pour que pour faire croire que
justement on n'a pas peur d'être vus
parce qu'on est toxique parce qu'on est
hyper dangereux et alors qu'en fait non
c'est juste du bluff en fait et ça
existe ça dans la nature ça existe dans
la nature et du coup ça aurait été
vachement marrant de montrer quelque
chose comme ça bon là ils sont juste
bleus et c'est dans cet épisode là qu'on
a le fameux car nos torts fameux car nos
torts qu'ils t'aiment grand comme ça
comme ça je t'aime et puis la femelle
qui dit mais si pour beaucoup donc bon
j'ai déjà expliqué plein de fois
pourquoi je trouvais que c'était pas
terrible comme comme idée donc je vais
pas revenir là-dessus notable il est
notable que le carnot tort fait un
cercle complètement en fait ils déboise
complètement un cercle
ce qui est un comportement qu'on voit
chez certains oiseaux modernes
il est notable que je me suis planté en
dix ans pendant le trailer que les que
les osthéos derme sur le dos était
correct scientifiquement chez carnot
tort non ils ne le sont pas
les travaux de christophe hendrix que je
cite dans ma vidéo indique qu'en réalité
il n'était pas du tout aligner là on
voit bien les rangées de ce thé au derme
sur le dos et en fait non il n'était pas
du tout alignés en rangées d'ostéo dern
il était plutôt au pifomètre donc c'est
quelqu'un qui me l'avait fait remarquer
dans les commentaires que je remercie du
coût et du coup je suis allé vérifier
effectivement c'est pas du tout comme ça
que ça se passe chez carnot tort donc
les petits bras je suis pas d'accord
pour revenir rapidement sur le pourquoi
bas parce que carnot tort parce que
d'une s'il avait les bras atrophié c'est
complètement débile de s'en servir pour
dire qu'ils les meilleurs reproducteurs
on voit plutôt tendre à utiliser des
choses hypertrophié pour montrer qu'on
est le meilleur pas des choses atrophiée
et la deuxième raison c'est qu'arnaud
tort a déjà des cornes on est un espèce
de patch de kératine là sur le visage
qui sont déjà de très bons candidats
pour des structures que qui pourraient
montrer comme ça voilà colorée avec du
sang et c'est pour montrer qu'il est le
meilleur en fait c'est déjà des
caractères sexuels des très bons
candidats pour être des caractères
sexuels secondaires il n'y a pas de lui
rajouter des bras colorés comme ça les
caractères sexuels secondaires je
l'avais pas expliqué dans la vidéo
précédente donc je vais l'expliquer
maintenant ce sont les bas par exemple
chez l'être humain ce sont les saints
voilà les hanches les muscles chez les
mâles c'est ça les poils les poils du
torse chez les mâles tout ça ce sont des
caractères sexuels secondaires sont les
différences entre mâles et femelles qui
se développe en fait et qui servent à la
séduction entre guillemets donc ça ce
sont des caractères sexuels secondaires
et donc les petits bras là que la
femelle n'a pas fallu et la femelle à
des petits bras mais elle n'a pas les
petits bras coloré donc les couleurs ça
c'est un caractères sexuels secondaires
et c'est utilisé pour la parade nuptiale
donc c'est à l'évidence un caractères
sexuels secondaires
moi j'aurais préféré voir ça sur les
cornes du a dû un gros patch bleus sur
les cornes et puis lui en train de faire
qui est dit comme ça ça a été très
marrant train de faire une petite danse
là comme un oiseau de paradis bon c'est
très spécifique aux oiseaux de paradis
les petites danses évidemment mais voilà
en train de faire une petite danse avec
sa tête comme ça en train de montrer ta
vu t'as vu comment j'ai les grandes
cornes
à l'acte ou aux rites et au lieu de ça
il utilise son seul organe atrophiée ça
n'a aucun sens donc ça j'étais pas
d'accord par contre là où j'ai été grave
d'accord avec cet épisode le miel le
miel évidemment évidemment [ __ ]
pourquoi pourquoi on n'a jamais vu ça
avant du mieux mais oui ne veut la fin
du crétacé le miel et les abeilles les
abeilles qui commence à caux évolué avec
le avec les plantes à fleurs du miel
quoi merde les abeilles elles sont là
elles ont elles ont déjà commencé leur
leur sont déjà en co évolution avec les
enjeux sperme alors c'est peut-être une
ruche un peu trop évolué pour une
abeille de l'époque mais et puis surtout
on la voit faire cette espèce de
comportement qui consiste à faire des
ondulations on voit les abeilles se
coordonner pour faire ces ondulations
encore une fois un invertébré avec un
comportement hyper complexe mais met
donc ça c'était peut-être un peu trop
dérivé pour une abeille du crétacé mais
bon façon ça se fossilise raja mais ce
genre de choses donc on a bien le droit
de faire ce qu'on veut mais mes du miel
que évidemment du miel
est évidemment qu'on voit un groupe
typique du crétacé prendre pour utiliser
ce miel donc les terres isin aux orres
évidemment on voit pas un nom un groupe
plus anciens comme les sauropodes
exploiter une ressource qui est nouvelle
comme le miel et ça c'est pareil c'est
pas anodin comme décision une fois de
plus c'est pas anodin ça veut dire que
les sauropodes ils vivent déjà dans un
monde qui les dépasse entre guillemets
alors que les terrines aux orres sont à
quai la ils apprennent des nouvelles
choses il exploite les nouvelles
ressources tout ça tout ça ça dit des
choses ça ça dit des choses c'est beau
c'est beau
et puis l'épisode se termine c'est
encore plus beau l'épisode se termine
sur la côte voilà la boucle est bouclée
l'épisode se termine là où la série a
commencé enfin la série se termine là où
la série a commencé
donc en conclusion je dirais bien
satisfaction je veux dire évidemment je
n'aime pas ces 45 minutes à dire d'un
crap et à des à répandre mon fiel sur
les épisodes mais fois déjà il y avait
du positif ce pauvre ai je pas été que
méchant mais oui le jeu je viendrai je
viens de dire là tous les trucs qui
m'ont dérangé mais c'est juste pour
donner une grille de lecture sur les
choses qui ne vont pas un c'est pas pour
c'est pas pour vous dissuader d'aller le
voir c'est juste quand vous le verrez
vous pourrez vous arrêter sur ces
différents points en vous disant c'est
vrai que là julien là julien il a dit
qu'il fallait se méfier savais même pas
forcément dire qu'il prendre ça comme si
c'était faux ça veut juste dire julien
elle a dit là il fallait se méfie donc
on va peut-être se méfier moi j'ai
apprécié la série avec deux trois petits
bémols par ci par là où je me dis ça
aurait pu être améliorée ça pue ça
aurait pu être fait autrement yakafocon
etc bref faites dans ce que vous voulez
en tout cas moi je vous souhaite un très
bon visionnage parce que j'espère quand
même vous avoir convaincus d'y aller et
je vous dis à très bientôt sur notre
chaîne salut